Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist.
Hier ist wieder das corona weekly vom vierzehnten mai zwanzig zwanzig und ich sag hallo zu pavel hallo.
Hallo tim.
Denn es ist wieder zeit das ganze zahlenmaterial was über deutschland heirat geregnet ist aufzuwiegen zu interpretieren und durch zu analysieren und alles besser zu wissen.
So wie wir das jetzt hier schon seit einiger zeit tun
und langsam kriegen wir auch ein bisschen übung habe ich so den eindruck auf jeden fall ist unsere liste für diese sendung wieder lang und da wird sicherlich
einiges zu holen sein wir wollen über zahlen sprechen bisschen auch was ich so nachrichten mäßig ergeben hat und auch in der ganzen diskussion um die digitale contact tracing sache haben sich auch ein paar neue,
ergeben und wird also nicht langweilig die war auch nicht langweilig oder pavel.
Im gegenteil ich habe das gefühl dass es hier langsam zu einer vollzeitbeschäftigung aus sich einfach nur auf dem laufenden
zu halten also.
Weil es halt so ein paar pflichtveranstaltung gibt natürlich wenn man reden will die trosten podcasts hören presse zu verfolgen die.
Berichte und pressekonferenzen dort teilweise reinzuschauen dann und dann.
Ja zu sehen wer sonst noch so was macht das feedback aufzubereiten ja und dann habe ich halt noch auch ein kleines tool ins netz gestellt aber da wollen wir später drüber reden.
Genau.
Blicken wir zunächst einmal auf das nachrichtengeschehen tatsächlich kam das so mehr oder weniger genau als wir die letzte sendung aufgenommen haben deswegen konnten wir das gar nicht weiter berücksichtigen da haben wir ja dann noch unsere schlüsse auch
gezogen oder zumindest die schlüsse die sogar allgemein gezogen wurden aus dieser heinsberg geangelt studie die ja dann final veröffentlicht wurde.
Kaum war das dann raus und wurde herumgereicht und dann damit ja auch die studie mal richtig veröffentlicht gab's allerlei kritik da haben sich dann diverse statistik profis und andere leute die irgendwie von mathematik was verstehen da drauf gestürzt und
kräftig den kopf geschüttelt und gesagt so ja leute alles schön und gut hier mit euren aussagen nur habt ihr da nicht was vergessen und dann wurde vor allem bemängelt
dass in diesem ganzen mathematischen oder statistischen auswertung kein oder ein falsches confidence intervall genannt wurde ich glaube keins.
Und kurz gesagt bedeutet dass so viel wie ja okay ihr mit eurer null komma drei sechs prozent infektionsstation zeit das hat man ja letzte woche ausführlich nochmal
was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Kann ja sein dass ihr auf diese rechnung kommt aber ihr müsst halt auch ausweisen welche unsicherheit in diesen zahlen drin steckt auf basis verschiedener
mathematischer parameter oder sonstiger rahmenumstände sowas wie ja ihr zählt tote aber
stellen wir auch noch leute später und so und ja da ging so ein bisschen hin und her ich habe so ein bisschen rausgehört somit
ja könnte so sein könnte aber auch irgendwie noch eine deutlich höhere dunkelziffer ergeben also bis zu faktor zehn zwanzig habe dann auf einmal alles gehört so.
Und nachdem wir uns ja letztes mal so ein bisschen ganz wohl gefühlt haben im bereich von sechs kann man eigentlich nur sagen.
Naja also diese studie hat uns jetzt glaube ich nicht wirklich voran gebracht.
Also ja nicht ganz sicher wir bewegen uns hier einfach im bereich von kleinen zahlen speziell bei den bei den todeszone irgendwie wenn du halt zehn fälle hast
ist halt jeder einzelne fall ich hatte dann dann halt mal
geguckt hatte der thorsten auch gesagt aber ich habe da mal oder hat mir auch beim letzten mal gesagt wie wie jeder einzelne fall mehr der der dann noch stirbt wie sehr der die zahlen alleine schon verändert
also ich fühle mich immer noch wohl mit sechs komma zwei fünf so ich glaube nicht an die dunkelziffer zwanzig und so weiter ich.
Kann auch gute gründe dafür angeben wesentlichen kann man auch später noch drüber reden die sinkende positiven quote bei den
corona tests trotz ausweitung so deutet nicht auf eine derart gigantische dunkelziffer hin.
Ja dann gab es unter anderem auch mal wieder eine pressekonferenz vom.
Und dabei diesmal saß nicht der wie heißt der wie leer.
Ja
Der chef sondern sein der vizepräsident vom schade und.
Führte in ruhigen besonderen worten der versammelten journalisten scharf nochmal aus
wie denn das nun mit dem r eilig genau ist so oder wenn wir heute auch nochmal mehr drauf eingehen es gab jetzt einen neuen aufreger nachdem sich es alle schon so wohlig warm am lagerfeuer
bequem gemacht haben kann dann so zwischendurch die meldung rein ja er liegt
bei eins komma eins und schon hatten alle wieder das den augen und brennende mülltonnen und so weiter weil wir werden alle sterben.
Und sagen wir mal so hörer konnten nur leise schmunzeln weil wir werden und genau diesen aspekt
des schwankenden erst hier wirklich jetzt schon mehrfach auseinandergenommen haben
und um das ganze dann noch zu toppen gegen ende seiner erläuterung also wo er wirklich nochmal ganz genau erklärt wie ist das mit dem er was kann man denn ansehen was kann ich nicht ansehen warum ist das so unsicher was was sagt das eigentlich aus was sagt das nicht aus ja und es guckt ja in die vergangenheit und now casting und all diese ganzen sachen also alles das was wir uns ja auch mal schon gefragt haben aber dann eben hier
in unserem eigenen diskurs uns erarbeitet haben hat er dann sozusagen nochmal
dargelegt in ruhigen worten und der absolute höhepunkt was willst du noch was dazu sagen.
Ja ja ja ich erinnere mich dass ich dass wir uns ja so ein bisschen aus dem fenster gelehnt habe ich gesagt er hat entschuldigung aber in meinem grafen in meinem sieben tages schnitt irgendwie ist da noch nichts über eins,
kommt vielleicht später ums versehen aber ja.
Naja und ich bin da müssen wir alles aus dem gesicht gefallen als er dann auf einmal das hier sagte.
Ja ist schon lustig wenn man so ich sage mal eigentlich als halber amateur seine seine
berechnungen macht und dann die profis eine woche oder wochen später dann nachziehen mit dem geglättete herbert das ist das war.
Die christliche logistik funktion.
Ja genau.
Ja das fand ich dann doch irgendwie ganz lustig auf jeden fall hat man gemerkt dass das ist ich will nicht sagen überfordert.
Aber unter anspannung ne also die sind
natürlich unter einer extremen beobachtung machen natürlich eine menge arbeit hauen auch in ihren situationsbericht einfach eine ganze menge informationen raus und da geht's ja um deutlich mehr nur als das ne aber natürlich
merkte man auch dass sie das in noch so ein bisschen glaube ich das händchen dafür fehlt wie man eben solche sensitiven
zahlen in der öffentlichkeit am besten jongliert ne weil man eben einfach nicht es nicht reicht rein für wissenschaftler klare zahlen zu haben sondern man muss eben ein gewisser hinsicht
ein geglättete also ein ein ein ein für die öffentliche wahrnehmung die ja auch mich vollständig verzögert ja und im schlimmsten fall auch leicht erregt ist auch irgendwie was bieten.
Das ding ist ja es ist ja nicht so dass pandemien bekämpfung so zu den routineaufgaben
gehört das ist die erste pandemien
glaube ich die uns hier ja wirklich erreicht hat und so die zahlen und die dimensionen und so das ist alles nicht
erprobt das ist also eigentlich ist vieles dort auch für das oder die wissenschaftler neuland weil
infektionen in so einer menge wurden halt nie getrackt,
so sie hatten halt nie so viele so viel material oder tausende von von meldungen aus denen man dann irgendwie was ablesen muss ich glaube
auch die meldest software ist gar nicht so richtig geeignet dafür solche trends in echtzeit ab
zu bilden das hat man dann am ende des jahres gemacht irgendwie hat man dann einmal geguckt wie es denn wie denn die sterblichkeit so gelaufen ist in so einer großen,
auswertung oder so ein vielleicht mal zwischendurch wenn die grippewelle war aber.
Ich sag mal so was und natürlich mit der öffentlichen aufmerksamkeit und mit täglichen meldungen und,
alles drängt und es geht wirklich um leben und tod und um die zukunft der nation und so das ist ja es ist schon keine angenehme situation genau dann kommen wir auch noch daher und machen alles martin ja.
Genau.
Aber muss sagen wir machen ja nicht alles madig ich finde wir sind einigermaßen fair und zurückhaltend bei dem was wir kritisieren und ich habe auch großen respekt vor dem was die leute machen aber wie gesagt das sie sind halt nicht perfekt so
und es ist halt auch neu für sie und so kommt es vielleicht zu der situation,
mit ein bisschen nachdenken und mit ein bisschen abstand und wenn man nicht so unter druck
steht fällt einem vielleicht das eine oder andere auf was wichtig ist dass den leuten vielleicht auch aufgefallen ist aber sie ist nicht vielleicht nicht für wichtig gehalten haben wie zum beispiel die wöchentlichen schwankungen.
Ja und vor allem hoffe ich ja auch dass ihn langsam mal klar wird welchen wert ist für sie doch haben kann wenn sie ihre daten auf eine art und weise veröffentlichen dass man da auch besser was mit anfangen kann jetzt hatten wir ja in der letzten sendung,
darauf verwiesen auf diese daten also das sind
die daten die jetzt nicht so ganz super präsent auf der webseite woanders etwas versteckt
rumliegen und die ja jetzt nicht diese typischen übersichten darstellen sondern das ist dann wirklich mal eine liste von datensätzen
die ganz konkret jeden einzelnen erfassten fall in deutschland dokumentieren.
Und da haben wir darüber gesprochen dass dir dann bei der analyse und dem versuch da über das erkrankungen datum was da
teilweise drin erfasst ist quasi eine eine etwas reales darstellung der.
Erkrankung verläufe zu bekommen weil ja eben meldung teilweise sehr viel später stattfinden aber manchmal liegen sie eben relativ nahe im erkrankungen statue und manchmal liegen sie.
Teilweise auch sehr weit weg davon beziehungsweise manchmal
gibt es halt auch eine meldung und da liegt eine erkrankung noch gar nicht vor sondern erst später statt also die sogenannten asymmetrischen fälle also die leute die den virus haben zufälligerweise
getestet werden zu dem zeitpunkt aber noch nicht krank sind aber es eben dann in der zukunft noch werden.
Da wolltest du ja dann so ein so eine glättung oder sagen wir mal so eine eine interpretation,
bauen um deine genauere voraussagen zum.
Genau ich wollte im prinzip das know how casting so ein bisschen nachbauen oder mein eigenes casting machen was sagen sie denselben zweck erfüllt.
Das problem ist aber dass das mit diesen daten nur.
So begrenzt möglich ist weil er eben tatsächlich das genaue eingangs datum
fehlt das kann man zwar wenn man dann wenn man jetzt die täglichen damms hat davon hat mir auch schon geredet kann man das dann versuchen zu berechnen oder nachzuvollziehen es ist aber nicht für jeden datensatz,
ein nicht für jeden fall ein eigener datensatz dabei sondern es werden eben auch fälle zusammengefasst sind dann halt sechs fälle.
In einem datensatz die dann idealerweise die gleichen.
Altersgruppe gleiches geschlecht und so weiter haben sollten.
Selbst erkrankungen datum.
Und genau und dasselbe erkrankung statue und dasselbe melde datum so.
So hundertprozentig schlau geworden daraus bin ich noch nicht mehr lina jetzt wir liegen jetzt mittlerweile sechzehn tage an daten doms vor und habe.
Da wirklich auch tage mit verbracht zu verstehen was denn da passiert von einem tag auf den,
anderen so zwischen den daten doms es gibt halt jeden tag einen kompletten damm mit hundertdreißigtausend datensätzen und am nächsten tag gibt's neun damm mit hundertdreißigtausend.
Und ein paar zerquetschte daten setzen so jetzt würde man denken okay.
Da sind dieselben datensätze wie gestern so plus ein paar neue.
Nee ist aber nicht so also ja es sind überwiegend.
Dieselben datensätze wie gestern so bis auf ein paar hundert so aber es.
Haben sich auch daten aus der vergangenheit geändert also es passieren da komische dinge also es sieht so aus.
Das einzige wie ich mir das erklären kann ist dass da jemand tagsüber an den daten rum und alle möglichen daten werte ändert erkrankung datum melde datum und dann die daten wieder abspeichert.
Und am nächsten tag kriegen wir dann einen neuen dump von den daten aber ohne irgendwie record aids also ohne dass wir jetzt wissen können,
welcher welcher datensatz zu welchem datensatz von gestern eigentlich wirklich passt so und.
Ja also das macht das ganze halt
etwas schwierig also es fehlt sowohl es gibt keinen eingangs datum weil es gibt halt keine fälle das ist halt ich meine wut man muss fairerweise zu sagen
die liste ist jetzt nicht,
dafür gemacht oder wird nicht so beworben mit irgendwie hier ist jetzt die ganze historie sondern hier könnt ihr euch die veränderungen angucken die von zwischen gestern und heute
stattgefunden haben und dann gibt's halt in den datensätzen wilde korrektur werte
so von minus ein toten und minus irgendwie fünf erkrankte bestehen dann da
plötzlich drin und da muss man halt ja die negativen und die positiven erkrankten und toten von gestern und von heute abziehen oder zusammenzählen oder auch nicht
so ist wenigstens da steht steht der anleitung wie man auf die zahlen kommt so aber ja also es ist mühsam.
Minus ein toter das war doch ostern.
Ja genau wie das ein toter ja also wir haben.
Sind nicht wirklich auferstehung sondern es ist nur zeitversetzt eigentlich in diesen meldungen aber das macht es halt einfach wirklich ein pain in mit diesen daten zu arbeiten.
Hast du denn neue daten erhalten wir hatten ja aufgerufen ob jemand noch backups hat.
Ja erhalten noch nicht es hat mir jemand welche angeboten so ich habe das hatte aber noch keine zeit des wahrzunehmen und mit jedem weiteren tag der natürlich jetzt auch vergeht.
So reichern sich meine daten jetzt auch an das heißt es drängte jetzt auch nicht so.
Gut wir werden auf die nutzung dieser daten gleich nochmal eingehen schauen wir doch jetzt mal auf die aktuelle situation der situationsbericht vom.
Was ist denn diese woche passiert oder was wo wo stehen wir denn jetzt nach einer woche.
Wenn man sich jetzt die reihen offiziellen zahlen für ganz deutschland einfach nur anguckt wie wir es bisher auch gemacht haben also die.
In der summe so dann stellt man fest dass die ja.
Sich so auf mehr oder weniger auf vor wochen niveau befinden also nicht weiter runtergegangen.
Sind eigentlich was ich denn auch in,
von eins komma eins äußert den jetzt sagen mein wochenendurlaub schnitt berechnung auswirft also sprich genauso viel fälle,
in gesamtdeutschland wie in der vorwoche also.
Nichts ist runtergegangen aber auch nicht ja doch also es ist man sieht auch anstiege durchaus aber im wochenschluss eben nicht.
Man muss dazu sagen und das ist ja auch beim nochmal gesagt worden und gilt jetzt ab jetzt sowieso immer wir haben jetzt insgesamt in deutschland nicht mehr viele fälle
wir reden jetzt hier für ungefähr tausend neu infektionsweg meldungen pro tag und das ist natürlich jetzt auf.
Achtzig millionen einwohner verteilt nicht besonders viel so das heißt es schwankt jetzt vor allem mit
ausbrüchen es gab hier die berichte ausbrüche natürlich in diversen altersheim pflegeheim dann in der schlacht industrie nicht in den fabriken aber dann eben die
arbeiter aus osteuropa die uns das billige kotelett da zusammen geschlachtet die.
Wohnen dann quasi auch da in so unterkünften eng beieinander ähnliches problem wie es auch schon in singapur gab und was ja dort auch dazu geführt hat dass er die zahlen auf einmal hoch ging und sie wieder unkontrollierte ausbrüche.
Hatten also all diese ganzen lokalen ereignisse reißen diese zahlen halt schnell auseinander.
Das ist das ist genau genau der punkt und trotzdem kann man sagen dass ich jetzt.
In der gesamten letzten woche der erwehrt auch jeden tag erhöht hat so und heute ist er jetzt erstmalig
über eins allerdings jag glaube ich wird er auch nicht.
Allzu weit hoch gehen es sieht für mich so aus als würde der jetzt erstmal um die eins bleiben aber.
Wenn man die zahlen jetzt interpretieren will ich das ist jetzt auch nichts neues dass man eigentlich mit den zahlen nur was anfangen kann oder.
Man die testfahren auch im auge haben muss so und bei den testfahren.
Ist es so dass die tests zugenommen haben zumindest von der achtzehnten auf den neunzehnten kalenderwoche wurden so achtzehn prozent mehr tests durchgeführt wir wissen's jetzt nicht
genau für die aktuelle woche noch nicht aber das.
Also wir sind jetzt kaffee.
Wir sind jetzt zwanzig genau und in kaffee neunzehn
wurden halt statt dreihundertfünfundzwanzigtausend tests in kw achtzehn wurden zweiundachtzigtausend tests in kaffee neunzehn durchgeführt also das eins komma eins achtfache achtzehn prozent
mehr so gleichzeitig ist die rate der positiv getesteten so von drei komma neun prozent auf zwei komma sieben prozent gefallen also sagen noch sagen deutlicher
als die tests ausgeweitet worden und das bedeutet jetzt zwei.
Der bericht ist auch erst gestern veröffentlicht worden deswegen ist es relativ frisch hat noch nicht viel zeit mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Aber zwei dinge bedeutet das wenn man natürlich mehr tests macht muss man davon ausgehen dass man auch mehr.
Positive kriegt es sei denn es sind nicht mehr positive da.
Oder man testet an den falschen stellen.
Ja oder man testet an den genau so das heißt wir haben aber mehr tests und.
Eine noch stärker sinkende quote in den tests.
Das heißt dass aber unsere meldet zahlen jetzt überhöht sind oder wir natürlich wenn wir mehr testen,
kriegen wir halt auch mehr meldungen wenn nicht im gleichen maße sagen die zahl der positiven fälle runtergehen würde was sie nicht tut so das heißt dass die eins komma null.
Wahrscheinlich quatsch ist wir sind immer noch unter eins komma null sondern der anstieg ist meiner meinung nach jetzt wieder zu einem.
Überwiegenden teil auf.
Ein anstieg beim testen zurückzuführen ich habe es noch nicht genau durchgerechnet aber.
Also das mit dem test ist ja nochmal so eine ganz eigene wissenschaft ich glaube ich hatte dir auch ein neulich mal dazu einen,
hat die älteren längeren artikel geschickt der so aufgestellt hat welche auswirkungen es auf die berichteten zahlen insgesamt hat jena
dem welche test strategie man verfolgt und zu welchem zeitpunkt man
test jetzt mehr macht weniger macht et cetera also es hängt davon ab wie früh fängt man damit an dass natürlich am anfang sollte man möglichst früh testen aber dann hängt es eben gibt es eine interessante kurven die lassen sich jetzt etwas schwer erklären aber wesentlichen.
Konnte ich da rausziehen wenn man test hochfährt dann hat das eben schon eben gesagt hast dann wird dann blickt man quasi auf mehr.
Und gerade am anfang sieht es dann aus dass ein ausbruch oder eine eine gesamtsituation sich schritt für schritt immer dramatischer darstellt.
Obwohl man eigentlich nur mehr.
Beleuchtet sozusagen von dem was da ist aber man nimmt es ja durch diese kontinuierliche meldung über die zeit.
Als einen anstieg da aber es halt einfach nur du hast halt einfach mehr lichtschalter angemacht und du du siehst halt.
Den den keller einfach siehst wo überall noch müll rumliegt der wird aber dann,
dadurch nicht unbedingt noch bedrohlicher irgendwann hast du dann so ein niveau erreicht wurde dann eben.
Angemessen testest also wo du so viele test hast dass du vielleicht ein gutes bild von dem tatsächlichen anstieg bekommst
also erstmal ketchup spielst und erstmal versucht überhaupt der situation herr zu werden einen überblick zu haben sodass deine relativen zahlen an den zunehmenden maße auch wirklich dem relativen.
Anstieg oder abfall entspricht.
Dann wiederum hat man aber das problem tests sind aufwendig test kosten geld dann geht eben wie jetzt hier vielleicht diese quote runter und dann sagst du ja irgendwann so.
Wir haben jetzt eine million test gemacht tausend leute gefunden was soll der scheiß können wir auch wieder runterfahren.
Und dann hast du natürlich wieder das nächste problem wenn dann doch wieder irgendwas ansteigt und du das nicht mehr siehst also wie man es auch dreht und wendet es gibt da keine
richtige antwort auf das ganze weil es von so vielen parametern abhängt dass man es eben auch nicht unbedingt frei gestalten kann nichtsdestotrotz denke ich mal ist es angemessen.
Gerade jetzt bei diesen schwierigen berechnungen mit insgesamt niedrigen zahlen
das zumindest noch mit zu berücksichtigen und ich finde es insofern bisschen schwierig als dass wir eben auch darüber keine wirklichen soliden zahlen bekommen weil diese tests sind ja jetzt nicht irgendwie in irgendeinem datensatz drin sondern das kann man sich jetzt aus irgendeinem pdf,
schön formatiert rauskratzen und es sind ja auch nur
gesamtzahlen für die bundesrepublik deutschland was wir nicht haben ist wieviel test haben jetzt in welchem landkreis stattgefunden wie viele tests von waren davon positiv und wie viele waren.
Negativ also die positiven kriegen wir ja mit ne aber die die die die eben nicht was wir nicht gesehen haben.
Man kann vielleicht einfach sagen dadurch dass sagen die vorschriften wer getestet wird und wer nicht,
geändert wurden kann man eigentlich die zahlen mit
sozusagen bevor das teddy test strategie oder die test vorschriften geändert wurden nicht ohne weiteres mit den zahlen von
davor vergleichen also sprich eigentlich beginnt quasi eine neue zahlen reihe oder muss das
irgendwie symbolisieren jetzt und
ich würde sagen dass man wenn man mit der alten test strategie weitergefahren dass von ungefähr größenordnungsmäßigen zehn bis zwanzig prozent eigentlich abziehen muss von den
zahlen der
der neunzehnten woche wenn man sie ins verhältnis mit der achtzehnten setzen will und mit den aktuellen zahlen dann genauso also satz wird
zeit jetzt nachdem jetzt endlich der geglättete erwerb eingeführt wurde
wäre es dann vielleicht noch jetzt zeit für den,
test zeit korrigierten wert als nächstes der nämlich ziemlich sicher noch unter eins.
Was jetzt nicht heißt dass jetzt alles ist so aber ja die situation.
Sieht meiner meinung nach ein bisschen besser aus als es die reinen zahlen jetzt von der letzten oder von den letzten beiden wochen widerspiegeln.
Bei den tests da halt was passiert.
Ist lost so,
trotzdem wäre es natürlich wünschenswert der herr trosten hat heute in seinem podcast glaubt ihr hast du heute noch nicht gehört ich habe grade noch kurz vor sendung beginn nochmal durchgehört hatte sich auch nochmal dazu geäußert
zu dem richtigen r wert und ich glaube er bezog sich auch auf eine passende studie dazu die festhielt das ist ja jetzt bei der.
Politischen abwägung wo man eigentlich hin will ja also was ist denn eigentlich das er was wir haben wollen da kann man halt auf der einen seite sagen.
Ja
mit dem ding hier ja auf null komma eins null komma null eins und corona und dann dann war's das problem nur dass es halt nur zu erkaufen unter einem totalen
space style look down und das ding ist halt nur das schädigt wie wir ja gesehen haben.
Die fortlauf der der wirtschaft und damit ja auch den tatsächlichen finanziellen aber auch medizinischen zustand.
Der bevölkerung also ist ja jetzt nicht so dass man jetzt einfach mal irgend so eine maßnahme ewig durchziehen könnte und keiner nimmt schaden,
gibt's alle möglichen berichte und leute die sich umbringen und depressionen haben und keine ahnung und leute die nicht richtig behandelt werden können oder aus anderen gründen unter dieser situation
leiden oder im aus mangel an betreuung oder mangel an dann an zugang auch zu intensivmedizin.
Entweder weil keine kapazitäten da waren oder weil irgendwas weil weil eine operation verschoben wurde von der man annahm dass sie verschoben werden konnte aber dann eben doch folgen hat uns
so weiter und so weiter außerdem dass man eben die wirtschaft auch.
Umso schwerer natürlich wieder angefahren bekommt umso mehr sie runtergefahren wurde.
Also es geht jetzt nicht generell waren es zeigt sich glaube ich auch gerade bei den
früheren pandemien war der spanische flur das einfach die länder die am schnellsten am stärksten reagiert haben in der ersten phase später auch am besten wieder recover konnten wenn sie
am anfang sehr schnell reagiert haben aber dass man jetzt in dieser zwischenphase in der wir jetzt dieser phase zwei dieser okay wir haben's jetzt unter kontrolle gebracht im sinne von
wir können das nachfolgerversion folgen wir wissen wo was passiert wir haben relativ guten blick die sinne sind geschärft ja erheben viele daten wir machen viele test ja jetzt ist ja die frage okay.
Welchen er hätten sie denn jetzt gern und dann war so die aussage naja zeigt sich bei diesem studie so ein erwerb von null komma fünf.
Wäre eigentlich ganz geil weil da drunter ersparst du dir nicht so viel tote ja.
Bringt nicht so viel schadet aber überproportional eben der wirtschaftlichen tätigkeit und auch der potenziellen recovery der der wirtschaft
aber eben so über null komma sieben fünf eben schnell dann auch wieder problematisch mit dem.
Medizinischen situation belastung dieses unter etcetera und eben allmöglichen wieder ausbruch also keine ahnung wie viel wasser das hält aber
das wäre jetzt sagen wir mal vielleicht auch so ein idealwert die wir jetzt bis wir weitere faktoren haben mal so an die wand hängen können somit wie kommen wir denn da hin derzeit sind wir nicht unbedingt direkt auf dem weg dahin.
Ja ist mal wir hatten das thema ja auch beim letzten mal glaube ich auch kurz angesprochen es geht halt nicht um.
Jetzt gesundheit gegen wirtschaft wie das oft so,
dahin gestellt wird sondern es geht halt auch um gesundheit der einen gegen gesundheit der anderen so dass da muss man tatsächlich im blick behalten problem ist natürlich,
dass wir das jetzt
die gesundheit der einen nämlich corona können wir so einigermaßen quantifizieren da haben wir jetzt zahlen was die gesundheit der anderen angeht nämlich die ganzen folgen kappen wir natürlich tief im dunkeln und es ist natürlich immer ganz ganz schwierig
in so einer situation wo man
da gar keine zahlen hat oder nicht nicht weiß so was zu tun so und,
meine das ist dann halt 'ne situation eben,
für die politik so alles was was klar ist kann die verwaltung machen und politik macht halt wo man halt keine ahnung von hat was man eigentlich tun soll so.
Bisschen überspitzt.
Aber es ist halt die aufgabe so da muss man dann halt bewerten und da kommt dann gefühl und emotionen und wie wird es aufgenommen und mit rein so das ist halt politik wenn man die
die ursachen nicht identifizieren kann warum
etwas ist wie es ist dann ist es aufgrund von politik so weil irgendjemand sich überlegt hat oder eine gruppe von leuten sich überlegt hat dass es jetzt dass man das gerne irgendwie in die richtung bewegen.
So und er hat bei dem jetzt gesundheit der einen gegen gesundheit der anderen ja kann man.
Sollte man weder das das eine noch das andere einfach komplett außen vor lassen und insofern gebe ich dir da recht es ist.
Es ist natürlich auch so.
Also mit lockerungen alleine ist es ja auch nicht getan weil natürlich viele dinge selbst wenn sie nicht verboten nicht tun.
Leute passen halt viele zwar nicht mehr so aber trotzdem passen die leute noch auf und mit dem reisen und.
Und alles ist das so eine sache und je höher.
Natürlich ist umso länger bleibt diese zeit der unsicherheit oder diese bedrohung bleibt halt auch bestehen und die macht halt auch negative wirtschaftliche effekte das heißt schweden nur vielleicht noch noch hinkommen dann ja auch gesagt na ja gut wir haben zwar keinen schatten gemacht aber die leute sind trotzdem nicht in die restaurants gegangen
ja und ja und das das das problem ist,
auch jetzt mit der gesamtzahl der der toten bis jetzt also es im schnitt schon die leute so zehn bessere lebenszeit verlieren.
Corona sterben das ist jetzt nicht nur so dass die dass das die ganzen alten sind die sowieso gestorben wären das also da gibt's studien das dem
mittlerweile wohl wohl nicht so ist und viele dieser leute so die
die sind auch noch aktiv produktiv und wenn man die verliert dann verliert man auch einen teil seines bruttoinlandsprodukts und zwar für für immer so also es ist halt auch wenn man da wirtschaftlich,
rechnet.
Willst du halt auch einfach möglichst wenig leute verlieren punkt auch aus wirtschaftlichen gründen und man möchte natürlich schon gerne auch wieder so schnell wie es geht,
wieder normalität herstellen.
Aber da kommt dann natürlich die internationale situation dann wieder rein es hilft natürlich wenig wenn du als erstes land gut was heißt wenig,
also es ist natürlich schön wenn du halt schnell mehr oder weniger corona frei bist aber bei den wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen und so ist es.
Halt hilft es halt auch nicht alleine die wirtschaft hochzubringen wenn die nachbarländer oder wenn irgendein land was was wichtig ist
da noch nicht mitzieht
oder es halt nicht passt weil du und du dadurch halt dann den reiseverkehr beschränken oder die leute unter quarantäne stellen musst und so das ist ja also ganz so einfach ist es ist es halt da auch nicht und ich
danke
so soll ich die zahlen kenne auch mit null komma sieben fünf das ist so der tiefste wert den wir bisher hatten im wochenendurlaub schnitt,
und mit dem würden wir tatsächlich gut fahren im moment.
Sagt vermutlich sind wir eher irgendwo bei null komma acht null komma neun.
In der in der gegend tatsächlich ja und.
Sag mal so solange der sich unter null komma neun befindet sieht man auch wenigstens noch einen rückgang so dann hat man wenigstens noch das gefühl okay es wird halt,
weniger es wird besser so was auf gar keinen fall geht ist halt über eins.
Über eins ist halt ein no-go aber damit natürlich jetzt das problem.
Wieder ja kleiner die zahlen werden umso schneller treibt halt dann eine neue ausbruch den er wert über eins eigentlich.
Wird er umso wertlose je kleiner die zahlen.
Werden nimmt eigentlich die aussagekraft von zunehmend ab das heißt wir müssen uns irgendwie.
Neue anhaltspunkte nehmen um den gefühl zu kriegen wird es jetzt besser oder schlechter.
Aber bevor bevor wir darüber sprechen sollten wir vielleicht nochmal kurz über die maßnahmen sprechen die jetzt auch schon ergriffen wurden also die neuen lockerungen
auch das kam genau zu dem zeitpunkt als wir gerade unsere sendung aufgenommen haben letzte woche rein deswegen haben wir das noch nicht aufgegriffen.
Beziehungsweise kurz danach als ich sind podcast geschnitten hatte da heißt es nun also.
Es dürfen diverse dinge die will ich jetzt gar nicht alle aufzählen wieder getan werden oder mit weniger einschränkungen getan werden alle läden dürfen jetzt aufmachen unter bedingungen etcetera und so weiter.
Und vor allem weil man sich nicht wirklich so richtig konkret auf irgendwas einigen konnte oder zumindest vielleicht auch ein bisschen.
Schwierig ist jetzt zu sagen der bund schreibt vor die dinge haben so und so zu laufen und dann gelten diese regeln sowohl für so einen spärlich.
Bewohnten
viele hunderte quadratkilometer umfassende gemeinde in mecklenburg-vorpommern wie für den prenzlauer berg in berlin ja das,
das kann ja nicht sein dass der herrschen andere bedingungen da herrscht eine andere wirtschaftliche bedingungen der herrschen andere soziale bewegung etcetera andere anforderungen
dementsprechend ist es klar dass es auf diesen ländern ebenen oder sogar auch auf landkreisebene geregelt werden muss und deswegen gibt's jetzt ein neues warnsystem
in gewisser hinsicht was sagt wenn pro einhunderttausend einwohner im wochenmitte.
Innerhalb eines landkreises fünfzig neue infizierte auftauchen
also man schaut sich nur ein landkreis an man mittelt den wert über die woche also nimmt dann auch wieder mit der christlichen logistik
die schwankungen heraus und rechnet das eben relativ zu der einwohner stärker dann dürfen da eben maximal fünfzig bei rauskommen
das ist jetzt sozusagen so eine so eine grenze aber das ist jetzt nicht so eine das fallbeispiel feldgrenzen sondern das ist so,
wenn der punkt erreicht wird oder wenn absehbar ist dass er erreicht wird oder je nachdem wie schnell man sich dem gerade auch annähert und wie nachhaltig das ist ist halt das jeweilige land bundesland
gezwungen mit dem landkreis zusammen entsprechende maßnahmen zu.
Beschließen und durchzuführen während es ansonsten eigentlich im wesentlichen landkreisen habe ich das in zumindest interpretiert überlassen wird ist das
dann entsprechend zu steuern sprich die gesundheitsämtern tun ihre sache wie sie sonst auch tun und versuchen der situation herr zu werden.
Mal umgerechnet auf berlin wären das zweiundzwanzig neu gemeldete infektionen pro woche.
Ja ich hatte auch schon auf twitter gesagt also die sozusagen die die fünfzig.
Pro woche des ist.
Pro hunderttausend ist eigentlich keine grenze das ist ein freibad fast machen zu können was man.
Aber gut immerhin ist es eine eine zahl und ich fand's halt auch grundsätzlich wichtig dass es schon auch klare vorgaben gibt von oben die differenziert sein sollen weil die leute vor ort.
Natürlich unter massiven druck stehen so in so einem in so einem kreis wenn da sagen auch maßnahmen aufzuheben oder nichts zu.
Zu tun und wenn die und deswegen ist es für die auch einfach leichter wenn jetzt vom bund oder vom land idealerweise natürlich vom bund klare vorgaben da sind wo die leute dann sagen können ja
ok aber sorry so ist nun mal die
anordnung von oben kann ich jetzt nichts machen ja wenn die anordnung natürlich sinnvoll strukturiert sind wir sind,
in einer neuen phase jetzt drin und.
Das was halt vor jetzt noch zwei drei wochen an zahlen oder daten oder statistiken oder auch maßnahmen noch galt und wahr ist vergangenheit wir sind jetzt ja.
Eben in der anderen phase und die andere phase braucht neue tools und neue betrachtungsweise.
In berlin gibt es eine ampel die korona ein frühwarnsystem.
Das ganz interessant weil da werden im prinzip drei kriterien aufgeführt die jeweils nochmal eigene.
Werte und schwellenwertes haben und unterschiedliche sachen repräsentieren einerseits der reproduktion faktor für berlin der.
Der klassische und geglättet vielleicht auch geglättet wir wissen's nicht dann.
Neue infektionen je woche je hunderttausend also das was wir jetzt gerade genannt haben ist was das ziel ist und aber auch die auslastung und kapazität der intensivbetten.
Revolutionsfarben fand ich ein bisschen merkwürdig also grün ist sozusagen unter eins komma eins.
Ja gelb ist eins komma eins bis eins komma zwei und ab eins komma zwei ist rot also kann man sich schon mal drüber streiten,
neue infektionen halt pro monat tausend grün ist unter zwanzig.
Ab zwanzig bis dreißig ist gelb ab dreißig ist rot.
Also hier wird schon doch deutlich früher eine eine bremse gezogen oder zumindest ein rot signal gegeben.
Und bei den kapazitäten und den auslastung der intensivbetten ist es halt unter fünfzehn prozent dann von fünfzehn bis fünfundzwanzig und ab fünfundzwanzig ist.
Rot also wenn man sozusagen fünfundzwanzig prozent aller intensivbetten mitkov neunzehn erkrankten voll hat dann ist schon.
Ist schon alarm angesagt so und jetzt gibt's noch regeln wie denn das jetzt mit diesen lampen dann auch zur halten ist und.
Da sagen sie einfach naja wenn zwei ampeln gelb sind egal was dann muss die senatsverwaltung den senat
unterrichten also sprich die bürokratie muss der politik bescheid sagen dass jetzt hier mal gegenmaßnahmen eingeleitet werden sollen und wenn zwei ampeln rot sind dann muss dieser senat auch entsprechende maßnahmen zur eindämmung der pandemien,
beschließen soweit der senat von berlin findest du das ein.
Akzeptables modell beim erstens ja dann doch eher lässig drauf.
Ja also ampel finde ich grundsätzlich gut habe ich auch kommen wir noch zu,
so massen ampel ja ich finde.
Alles bei bei ist alles über eins ist rot,
das ist und gelb ist ich sagen so bis null komma neun und oder null komma acht und ich würde sagen grün ist so unter null komma acht
aber ja für berlin mag das auch gehen so weil berlin große stadt und so,
aber für viele landkreise mein schwankt es halt viel zu sehr
dass das halt sagt er eigentlich je kleiner die fälle werden und je kleiner die einheiten sind die man betrachtet also sozusagen schon allein auf bezirksebene oder so
ja es.
Schon einfach eine fragliche größe zunehmend ja und ja bei den.
Neuinfektionen gut die.
Der bund hat die fünfzig gesetzt berlin hat die die dreißig,
ich finde ja die die fünfzig wie gesagt absolut rot
und
unter achtzehn oder zwanzig würde ich sagen kann man so ein bisschen sich sich entspannen
und grün so würde ich bei fünf setzen und sagen wenn's unter fünf ist denn.
So so würde ich und hab ich die schwelle werte gesetzt
aber das ist natürlich eine politische geschichte jetzt wieder weil guter spielt auch ein bisschen klar kann man da jetzt auch wissenschaftlich argumentieren und so aber okay was mir unverständlich ist ist wie so einen positives r
und dann so fein abgestuft dass das halte ich für quatsch der rest ja.
Ok finde es gut dass sie überhaupt was gemacht haben und sich so zum handeln jetzt kompetent haben.
Wenn man erstmal so ein system hat dann kann man in den parameter immer noch feilen am ende wird eine rot gelb.
Grün wahrgenommen und wenn man dann irgendwie sagt okay beim erde haben wir uns ein bisschen vertan das skalieren wir jetzt mal anders dann dann ändert sich ja im prinzip nichts und vor allem ist halt auch relativ klar geregelt wann irgendjemand irgendwie,
aktiv werden muss und natürlich ist jetzt auch nicht so dass die dann beim überschreiten von grün auf gelb oder von gelb auf rot und das erste mal nachts aus dem schlaf gerüttelt werden sondern es sind natürlich dinge die permanent im blick
gehalten werden sollten und wahrscheinlich auch werden und von daher kann man das mal erstmal ganz entspannt sehen was es auch gab waren schulaufführung.
Sogar bei mir gehen jetzt alle kinder wieder zur schule.
Erzähl mal wie sich das praktisch abgespielt hat das werden sicherlich so meine tochter ist
studiert ist nicht mehr im schulpflichtigen alter deswegen kriege ich da jetzt nicht mehr so viel mit wie das denn jetzt mit der videos denn die schulverwaltung jetzt organisiert hat und mit welchem sicherheitsmaßnahmen sie das versehen haben und ob
jetzt schon wirklich praktikabler unterricht in nennenswerten umfang stattfindet das würde mich ja interessieren.
Also letzteres auf gar keinen fall ich rede jetzt hier anekdotisch evidenz von fünftausend siebter klasse und von daher.
Kann kann das also sowohl an anderen schulen als eben auch in anderen jahrgängen auch teilweise schon wieder anders,
aussehen aber man gewinnt so ein bisschen den eindruck dass die schulen relativ vorsichtig an die ganze sache rangehen also es findet jetzt in der regel eine klassen drittel statt.
Das heißt die klassen werden jetzt nicht mehr gemeinsam im gesamten klassenkasse unterrichtet sondern sind halt entsprechend aufgeteilt.
Und das ergibt relativ kleine gruppen von so was ich je nach klassengrößen dann halt so acht bis zwölf.
Mitglieder sozusagen eine eines eines eines drittels und die sind dann im klassenraum auch sehr übersichtlich platziert sodass man sagen kann dass er eben diese reine,
unmittelbare zusammensitzt kontakt situation erstmal ins herz ist.
Aber was halt noch viel wichtiger ist es findet halt extrem wenig unterricht in der schule überhaupt statt also wir hatten jetzt bisher einmal.
Ich glaube es waren also in einem fall war es eine anderthalb stunde im anderen war es glaube ich drei stunden unterricht.
Einem tag dieser woche also wir sind noch gar weit weg von einem normalen schulbetrieb.
Also anderthalb unterrichtsstunden pro woche und haben die vielleicht draußen stattgefunden oder.
Nee so schlimm war es nicht das war dann schon drin soweit ich das beurteilen kann nur.
Ich denke das war jetzt auch sagen wir mal der erste aufschlag aber grundsätzlich geht es eher darum den kindern jetzt überhaupt erstmal wieder einen bezug zur schule zu vermitteln.
Den kontakt zu den lehrern herzustellen also den unmittelbaren physischen kontakt dass man auch mal das gefühl gibt schule findet auch noch statt und es ist nicht nur dass ein leben aus hausaufgaben.
Sind denn die lehrer alle auch verfügbar ich meine wir leben bräuchte man nicht dreimal so viele lehrer jetzt wo man dreimal so viel klassen hat.
Na wenn man fünfmal so wenig unterricht macht halt nicht.
Sind denn ja was es mit alten lehrern und so die müssen.
Kann ich im einzelnen jetzt nicht beurteilen wer da jetzt verfügbar ist das ja jetzt auch nicht in dem sinne einen ausgedehnten fachunterricht gibt sportunterricht wegfällt und so weiter also überhaupt eigentlich unterricht ist
de facto hier in berlin im was mich betrifft ja findet normaler schulunterricht nicht statt kann man einfach mal so festhalten sondern es gibt eine.
Ein aufruf für sich auch mal in der schule zu treffen und da sind jetzt die ersten aufschläge gemacht worden jetzt muss man mal schauen wie das geht ich habe das gefühl es geht jetzt erstmal darum.
Faser eins den kindern zu signalisieren wir sind noch da schule ist für euch ein thema hier sind auch eure freunde ja.
Keine kuschelparty so aber ihr habt's jetzt mal wieder gesehen und so weiter das leben beginnt wieder und wir versuchen jetzt hier auch mal
prozesse zu etablieren mal euch das auch zu erklären wie wir uns das jetzt hier vorstellen und für uns ist das ja auch alles neu und dann geht man halt auch mal diese ganze hausaufgaben geschichte mal durch dass sie einfach auch mal feedback
kriegen die brauchen wir einfach irgendwie mal wieder dieses gefühl für für für schule dass das ist ja das.
Bei einem so bei anderen so aber es droht natürlich generell komplett abhanden zu kommen von der problematik dass viele kinder überhaupt gar keinen zugriff über internet haben und so weiter war abgesehen.
Ich hörte es wurde im vorfeld auch abgefragt nach irgendwelchen möglichen gesundheitlichen risiken oder infektionen im
umfeld so dass halt nicht auch nicht alle schüler und vermutlich auch nicht alle lehrer irgendwie zur verfügung stehen falls sich in deren nähe irgendwie was ereignet hat.
Mit sicherheit also kann mich jetzt gerade gar nicht daran erinnern ob wir da auch zu befragt worden sind kann kann sein.
Aber sicherlich werden auch einige lehrer weg gehalten von der schule und das ist natürlich das generelle problem ich meine in berlin ist es ja ohnehin schon immer schwierig gewesen mit der schule.
Und viele schulen sind froh wenn sie überhaupt mal aufm besetzung schlüssel von eins komma null kommen also für alle fächer überhaupt genug lehrer haben und da ist dann halt schon.
Alles auf kante genäht weil dann lehrer werden nochmal krank und so weiter und dann.
Fällt halt unterricht aus und all diese ganzen sachen und jetzt in so einer situation wo du halt unter umständen auf alle lehrer verzichten musst die bestimmtes alter erreicht haben und es sind in berlin eine menge
oder eben aus anderen gründen vorerkrankungen und etcetera gespräche immunsysteme haben,
vielleicht lehrerberuf ohnehin nicht optimal aber gibt halt diese fälle das spielt halt jetzt hier noch mit rein,
ich vermute mal das ganze wird jetzt insofern ein bisschen fahrt aufnehmen dass man einerseits guckt okay wie läuft das b schaut wie man dann eben die präsenz da bisschen verstärken,
kann indem man sich dann eben auch mal bestimmte prozesse und den kindern auch anerziehen.
Und erarbeitet um dann eben aber auch die epidemiologische auswertung abzuwarten nämlich ok.
Hat das jetzt im prinzip geklappt oder war jetzt allein dass wir uns mal ein paar stunden getroffen haben schon problem ja also man muss sich da auch rantasten und hat immer das problem dass natürlich die antworten frühestens drei vier fünf wochen später bekommen kannst
wenn überhaupt so und wenn sich das halt abzeichnen sollte dass es irgendwie alles das maßnahmen ergriffen wurden die irgendeiner form kontrollierbar sind.
Da kann man ja angehen und sagen okay dann halbieren wir die klassen nur noch.
Oder wir legen sie ganz zusammen oder wir erhöhen die zeit die in der schule verbracht wird also man dreht es ganz langsam wieder hoch aber dieses schuljahr.
Das ist natürlich zerfasert also das ist das ist das kann weg.
Da ist da ist glaube ich nicht mehr viel zu holen habe ich den eindruck klar es wird halt irgendwie stoff reingepackt und wird noch die ein oder andere arbeit reingeschrieben aber es halt einfach nur.
Macht aber glaube ich auch durchaus sinn weil das problem ist hatte ich halt auch dargelegt.
Muss damit rechnen dass du in berlin so bis zu ja ich sage mal jeder je nach bezirk jeder hundertfünfzig bis dreihundertfünfzig ungefähr infiziert sein kann
so
und wenn du dir überlegst so schulen wir haben im schnitt dreihundert die berliner schulen meistens alle mehr so bis zu tausend schülern ich weiß nicht wie es bei euren schulen aussieht aber.
So ein paar hundert auf jeden fall.
Das heißt die wahrscheinlichkeit ist halt schon sehr groß dass du am ersten tag der eröffnung schon jemanden dabei hast der sich dann als infiziert herausstellt so
hinterher zumindest ich sag mal bei jeder zehnten schule wirst du das das haben und mit ungeschützten normalen schulunterricht
müsstest du halt ruckzuck gleich jede schule oder halt einen großen prozentzahl der schulen innerhalb von ein zwei wochen wieder zumachen weil du corona fälle an der
an der schule hast so deswegen wird das wohl noch ein bisschen so weiterlaufen müssen ist es auch sinnvoll dass so zu tun weil ich war schon etwas beunruhigt das normaler unterricht
stattfinden würde aber so denke ich kann es jetzt wahrscheinlich verantworten ist
macht aber jetzt auch mal,
vom hinblick wissensvermittlung jetzt nicht so viel sinn aber gut die sozialen kontakte zu halten wahrscheinlich unter dem aspekt und irgendwie,
sagen schon mal rück rückkehr zur normalität vorzubereiten dass es vielleicht das was man im moment
machen kann aber ja.
Sinnvoller unterricht wahrscheinlich findet offen offensichtlich derzeit noch nicht statt.
Außerdem im gespräch sind natürlich derzeit so grenzöffnung und natürlich auch die urlaubs perspektive hatten wir ja auch schon mal angesprochen
da muss man mal abwarten wie das ist ich vermute mal
ohnehin für pendler muss es da lösungen geben keine ahnung wie die aussehen werden und ob urlaub praktikabel sein wird in anderen ländern da habe ich noch so meine zweifel.
Na ja ich meine ich hatte ja gesagt okay wenn wir uns alle am riemen reißen so und jetzt nicht.
Zu sehr nachlassen dann haben wir alle auch eine chance sogar im in den sommerurlaub,
wegzufahren sogar wahrscheinlich september sogar spanien nach italien später hatten wir auch gesagt ein zwei monate später aber spanien kann man
wahrscheinlich sogar für den september ins auge fassen es ist nicht mehr ganz sommer aber so wie es aussieht und mich würde es halt sehr ärgern wenn wir uns das jetzt alles vermasseln
und jetzt bei irgendwie sich das
e seitlich fortsetzt diese diese infiziere oder gar nach oben geht und wir wieder irgendwie neue maßnahmen brauchen weil eigentlich sind wir auf einem echt guten weg,
eigentlich ist es ende schon fast in sicht wenn man es jetzt nicht vermasseln.
Ja ja aber sie ist mir das ist ein thema auf anderen veranstaltungen die gerade auch in deutschland stattfinden die aber eine ganz andere richtung gehen also jetzt haben wir gerade so ein bisschen dieses problem der fake.
Ich meinte das ende von chorona ja.
Ja ich weiß dass du das ende meintest aber andere leute verstehen halt generell unter dem problem gerade was ganz anderes und von daher weiß ich nicht so richtig ob man da einfach so an den vernunft aller appellieren kann.
Das werden wir noch sehen aber im zusammenhang mit urlaub vielleicht noch ein hinweis habe ich,
einen artikel gesehen der sich mit der ansteckung in flugzeugen beschäftigt hat.
Und das ist ja ich glaube das hattest du auch schon erwähnt das ist bisher relativ wenig bestätigte fälle gibt es leute sich auf einem flug angesteckt haben.
Sind zwar infizierte eingeflogen und haben dann vor ort entsprechend virus verbreitet aber
weiß nicht ob's
wenig fälle oder keine sind auf jeden fall ist es jetzt kein großes problem es gibt keine super spray event in flugzeugen wo man ja auf den ersten blick denken würde oh alle sitzen eng beieinander stunden
lang et cetera ja das das ist ja der totale terror und natürlich haben leute da jetzt auch ihre reservierung da gegenüber das wird man wahrscheinlich nicht mitkriegen und ich würde mir das glaube ich auch fünf mal überlegen ob ich jetzt einen flug antrete.
Aber flugzeuge sind üblicherweise recht gut belüftet und haben auch so eine art vertikalen luftstrom ich weiß nicht ob du mein flieger gefurzt hast.
Nein nein also.
Nein sowas würde ich doch nicht tun.
Natürlich aus reinwissenschaftlichen gründen immer ausprobiert um zu sehen.
Genau der punkt das ist nämlich die information also einerseits ist es eben genau wie du sagst also es ist vertikal und zwar von oben nach unten also die entlüftung zieht.
Und man kennt das ja wenn man oben diese dinger da aufdreht dann bläst es ordentlich nach unten und so tut es das generell sprich der luftstrom ist vertikal von oben nach unten und im boden wird dann entsprechend abgezogen keine ahnung wo der überall die löcher sind aber so
findet das statt und außerdem sind eben all diese ganzen luftwege dann mit entsprechenden filtern.
Ausgestattet die wohl fast hundert prozent der partikel rausholen und dementsprechend ist halt dieses kernproblem von viele leute in engen räumen ja dass ich nämlich a rio sohle ausbreiten hier so überhaupt nicht gegeben.
Und du hast noch eine extrem trockene luft,
wo man auch mal sehen muss wie sich das auswirkt aber tendenziell hilft trockene luft
auch so ich wollte da auch jetzt wo ich die
historischen daten dann auch habe wollte ich auch mal gucken ob ich dann das mit dem wetter korrelieren kann dazu muss ich mir dann aber noch wie möglichst
wetterdaten reihe mit luftfeuchtigkeit und temperatur für die landkreise besorgen und dann wollte ich mal gucken
so da sinnvolle korrelation bei rauskommt oder nicht das wäre doch immer.
Zur landkreisen kommen wir gleich vielleicht noch abschließend zu dem flugzeug thema also so ein flugzeug ist normalerweise tauscht innerhalb von drei minuten den kompletten luft inhalt einmal aus und das beruhigt in gewisser hinsicht weil das bedeutet.
Das ist jetzt kein bus.
Hoffe also theorie scheint,
die wir hier geäußert haben scheint sich zu bestätigen dass fliegen vergleichsweise
sicher ist so zumal wir bei den aktuellen zahlen der gut je nachdem so sitzt.
Mindestens in der in der hälfte der flieger so sitzt auch niemand drin der infiziert ist.
Das kommt noch dazu aber selbst wenn es halt so ist ist es halt unter umständen kein großes problem.
Damit kommen wir dann zu der viel angekündigten geschichte mit den landkreisen das haben wir also gelernt erstens mit.
Ist es etwas schwierig vor allem mit diesen ganzen globalen zahlen flatternde erst etcetera und außerdem haben wir eben jetzt noch diese landkreis bezogene regelung für künftige ampel ausschläge
und die daten die wir auch schon angesprochen haben liefern ja
genau diese informationen also ist ein datensätze für einzelne fälle aber die beziehen sich dann immer auf einen landkreis der explizit in jedem datensatz gemeldet ist weil,
da kommt her das ist quasi original also das entsprechende gesundheitsamt hat das dann eben
gemeldet sodass man diese daten nehmen kann und mal einen blick drauf werfen kann wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus in den landkreisen.
Da hast du mal was vorbereitet.
Genau ich meine es gibt ja auch seit ich weiß gar nicht wie lange nicht von anfang an aber.
Gibt es ja auch einen offizielles tool vom wo man sich auch die landkreise.
Anschauen kann so schön auf einer karte farblich ein.
Gefärbt und dann sogar auch auch suchen das heißt man hat da irgendwie jetzt grafisch auf jeden fall was,
ja aber irgendwie fand ich das.
Unbefriedigend so ich hatte nicht das gefühl dass mir diese eingefärbte landkarte jetzt wirklich einen einen britz hinreichend präzisen blick,
vermittelt zumal ich halt auch drauf rumklicken muss
um jetzt irgendwie zahlen miteinander zu vergleichen und es fehlen mir auch in dieser kreistag
ein paar ganz wichtige angaben ich kann nach zwar die zahl der todesfälle ablesen und sie haben jetzt die fälle in der letzten woche
mit reingebracht und die fälle pro einwohner die überhaupt bisher passiert sind aber das.
War es dann schon das heißt ich weiß nicht gehen die zahlen rauf oder runter in dem landkreis wie stark
gehen sie rauf und runter und bei den landkreisen die hell sind wie hell sind die denn jetzt tatsächlich und seit wann und
so also ja ich habe ich hatte nicht das gefühl ne
einen blick zu haben was passiert denn jetzt wirklich in den kreisen so und deswegen habe ich halt.
Auswertung in tabellarische form gemacht eine tabelle die halt genau all diese werte die ich vermisst habe enthält,
und man dort suchen und sortieren kann nach allen möglichen werten und außerdem diese werte.
Ampelmännchen auch eingefärbt sind wobei es eigentlich eine fünffache ampel ist für viele werte das heißt es gibt rot gelb grün
aber es gibt halt noch rot hinterlegt oder rot blinkend
grün hinterlegt so es ist sozusagen dass das grüne grün oder das absolute grün und das rote das wirklich beunruhigende rot und.
Außerdem als bonus da man halt so schön sortieren kann gibt es eben noch einen
risiko wert in der tabelle und ein ranking nach dem risiko wert so wir haben können
also dann gucken so was ist der gefährlichste landkreis gerade in deutschland und wo
ist es wirklich wirklich,
euch sowohl es absolut nichts los und eben alles dazwischen und da man halt sehr schön rauf und runter scrollen kann oder auch nach namen suchen kann und so habe ich jetzt das gefühl
erstmals und tatsächlich so einen so einen blick für so ein gefühl für das geschehen im
land zu haben und was sich was sich da tut und.
Es ist das bild ist tatsächlich tag und nacht kann man sagen wenn man landkreise vergleicht so landkreisen und sagen sind so.
Emma zwischen fünfzig und vierhunderttausend so im,
prinzip einige als die berliner bezirke sind halt auch einzeln drin jeweils.
Ja und das bild könnte nicht diverser sein in deutschland
wenn wir jetzt einfach mal einen blick auf die spitzenplätzen werfen von heute dann ist da freising cosfeld
sonneberg berchtesgadener land coburg und der erzgebirgskreis alb-donau-kreis,
gegen rosenheim,
und borken sind so die top ten um sie einmal verlesen zu haben aber ja jeder kann am besten selber einen blick drauf werfen dort.
Haben wir jetzt teilweise werte entweder die wo wir in der letzten woche.
Achtundsiebzig oder in einem fall von cosfeld hundertvier fälle gehabt.
Haben pro hunderttausend einwohner,
was eine zwei komma sieben wochen also fast verdreifachung gegenüber der vorwoche darstellt und das bringt halt großfeld auf den zweiten platz.
Werden sehen wie stabil die die tabelle ist aber ein ausbruch.
So in einem altenheim oder krankenhaus kann sofort ein landkreis an die spitze der tabelle katapultieren und
der risiko wert entspricht natürlich in so einem fall nicht in tatsächlich ein risiko falls tatsächlich die leute alle sich wirklich nur in dem altenheim befinden aber
aber erstens gehen wir von einem von der dunkelziffer faktor von sechs komma zwei fünf aus das heißt das auf jeden gezählten infizierten wer davon ausgehen können dass fünf weitere.
Unentdeckte draußen rumlaufen und worauf es ist auch feuer oder wo sag mal ein infiziertes ist sind auch noch fünf weitere könnte man sagen die von denen man offensichtlich nichts weiß.
Ja und die können natürlich die infektionen.
Weiter treiben und dann ist es so dass ja die leute in so einem krankenhaus oder altersheim oder sonst wie nicht weggesperrt sind da arbeiten ja wiederum leute da sind pfleger und andere und.
Trotz aller vorsichtsmaßnahmen die man da getroffen hat um das zu minimieren kann man halt auch nicht ausschließen dass da was raus transportiert wurde schließlich wohl auch was rein transportiert offensichtlich da kann da auch was raus transportiert werden so insofern.
Halte ich das verdient hintergrund durchaus valide und zu sagen ah das ist ja nur ein altenheim oder das ist ja nur das sind ja nur die
arbeiter in der siedlung.
Ja vielleicht aber kann ich es garantieren also der risiko wert ist eher sowas wie maximal risiko vielleicht ist es weniger riskant und.
Der wert ist so berechnet dass man sagen kann den zahlen nach ist einer von.
Also von risiko wert personen kann infiziert sein so das heißt das kann man so ungefähr eins als anhaltspunkt dann nehmen für.
Ja will ich da in den bus fahren oder wie wie viel infizierte können bei mir im bus sitzen und in im landkreis.
Zombie faktor wie groß ist der zombie faktor.
Und im schnitt im landkreis freising in einem vollbesetzten bus wären bis zu drei infizierte so so kann man den.
Den zombies den zombie quotienten solltest du auf jedes nennen.
Ja
Lass mich mal kurz dass ihr mal kurz aus meiner perspektive weil du bist ja jetzt natürlich auch komplett
drinnen hat sich ja auch vollständig eingegraben und auch extrem viel programmiert und daten durch genutzt ich habe ja sagen wir mal eher auf der anderen seite gestanden und die ganze zeit nur rum kritisiert was jetzt hier noch irgendwie anders sein müsste,
formatiert werden müsste etcetera aber ich finde das ergebnis an sich ist irgendwie ganz schön also was wir jetzt hier haben ist eine tabelle.
In der sind alle landkreise der bundesrepublik deutschland aufgeführt das sind insgesamt vier hundertundzwei und.
Für jeden landkreis sind zunächst einmal die daten so wie sie eben vom geliefert werden nochmal festgehalten.
Konkret die fälle also leute die einen kuvert erkrankt sind und.
Über die wir in einem bestimmten zeitraum jetzt erfahren haben ja also die gesamtzahl insgesamt ist natürlich ja auch nochmal wieder gegeben als größenordnung aber vor allem geht es darum zu schauen wie viele fälle wurden gemeldet.
In der letzten woche es in die letzten sieben tage außerdem ist angegeben.
Wie viele fälle sind gemeldet worden in den sieben tagen davor man könnte hier steht jetzt noch letzte woche vorletzte woche es geht jetzt nicht immer montag los oder so sollen wir reden hier eigentlich immer.
Letzte sieben tage und die sieben tage davor wodurch sich das ganze ja dann auch.
Logistik funktion einfach auch automatisch über die wochentags schwankungen verteilt.
Diese beiden werte werden also jetzt hier vor allem angezeigt und vor allem herangezogen um einen wert zu bilden nämlich den.
Wer hat den wert mit dem suffix weh,
sozusagen so ein hausgemachter ärgert der wesentlichen nichts anderes sagt als wie hat sich das dann den von dieser vorletzten woche zu der letzten woche
verhalten wie ist er mehr geworden ist es weniger geworden sind die fälle gleich geblieben ist der herbert der rws wert eins.
Doppelt so viele fälle ist der rws zwei.
Hälfte nur noch so viele gemeldet worden ist aber null komma fünf also so ähnlich wie der richtige große mehrwert aber.
Hier eben in so einem mikrokosmos als ein.
Gebildeter faktor um einfach ein gefühl dafür zu bekommen was passiert denn da gerade wie ist denn da die dynamik geht da gerade was ab dieser wert ist halt kein halt sehr schnell sehr groß werden bei dem spitzenreiter freising liegt er gerade bei einunddreißig.
Weil letzte woche vorletzte woche ist halt nur ein fall bekannt geworden und jetzt sind sie auf einmal einunddreißig haben sie also irgendwo 'ne tür aufgemacht und ganz viele fälle gefunden und natürlich schlägt sich das und so massiven wert nieder so hohe werte sind selten.
Kommen aber vor die meisten sind eher im einstelligen bereich zu finden.
So aus diesem wert berechnet sich jetzt also unter anderem diesen wert berechnet sich jetzt dieses risiko aber der fließen halt noch andere faktoren mit ein.
Und das ist ja dann schon relativ ausgebucht also zunächst einmal dieses.
Risiko eins zu ende also diese diese vergleichszahlen so dieses gefühlte wieviel zombies im bus ja das.
Geht erstmal natürlich von der einwohnerzahl aus so wie viel leute haben wir denn insgesamt
das teilte durch die dunkelziffer faktor über den wir jetzt auch schon gesprochen haben den du mit sechs komma zwei fünf angenommen hast also mit anderen worten für jeden real gemessenen fall.
Eines konkret gemeldeten kranken gehen wir einfach mal davon aus dass er noch fünf und noch ein viertel zombie.
Irgendwo rumlaufen weil wir einfach derzeit davon ausgehen müssen dass wir nicht.
Wir testen nicht alle und wir können das.
Ablesen das haben wir ja aus für dich auch nochmal gesprochen also diese gange studio gesprochen haben man guckt sich halt gezielt bestimmte bereiche an.
Wo man nicht nur erfasst wer ist krank und wäre es gestorben ja was nur falsch sterblichkeit aussagt sah man guckt sich halt auch an okay wir testen jetzt mal alle.
Im sinne von sehr sehr sehr viele im idealfall wirklich alle und.
Schauen mal wer war denn überhaupt infiziert also antikörper test infektionen etcetera das volle programm sodass man dann sagen kann aha okay.
Es hatten ja noch viel mehr leute den den virus sind aber irgendwie nicht krank geworden.
Jetzt vergleichen wir das eben mit dieser sterblichkeit und dann gewinnen wir eben.
Eine eine eine infektion sterblichkeit also wer stirbt wirklich wenn er sich das virus überhaupt einfängt und,
diese differenz zu dem zu der betrachtung der erkrankten die dann sterben sagt halt ein bisschen was darüber aus,
wie diese dunkelziffer ist weil man sieht ja wie viele leute sterben insgesamt.
Man sieht wie viele fälle dem gegenüberstehen und jetzt kann man halt hochrechnen so aha aber da waren es ja so viel infizierte also muss die zahl der infizierten sohn so viel höher sein
als wir gedacht haben dass diese dunkelziffer und die nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal an mit sechs komma zwei fünf das heißt man könnte diese ganze tabelle auch mit irgendeinem anderen wert ausrechnen.
Nur dann müsste man halten gutes argument haben warum man die andere zahl nehmen sollte und nicht diese kannst du nochmal herleiten warum du der meinung bist dass sechs komma zwei fünf derzeit so der goldstandard im dunkelziffer business ist.
Ja grundsätzlich glaube ich daran dass die also die modalität die sterblichkeit
bei null komma acht prozent
liegen von denen die es bekommen ja das waren viel niedrigere werte von null komma drei null komma vier oder so vor dem beobachtet und
wir haben
aktuell so zwischen sind wir glaube ich bei vier prozent ungefähr bei der fallstelle rate so wenn wir jetzt null komma acht nehmen
dann ist das sagen dass das fünffache aber die ist auch noch im steigenberger griffen weil auch noch leute sterben die infiziert waren und so und ich
und es ist halt auch keine konstante die dunkelziffer muss man auch sehen es ist nicht immer sondern die die dunkelziffer halt steigt und
sinkt eben auch mit zunehmend mit testen und aber auch im verlauf und kann sich auch regional total unterscheiden aber.
Wenn wir also fünf ungefähr die fünf durch null komma acht teilen
ja kommen wir halt auf diese zahl aber es kommen noch andere indizien dazu dass diese zahl auch stimmen könnte was vorher
auch bekannt war war das aufgrund der viel höheren ausgewiesenen sterblichkeitsrate in manchen herr spitzenreiter mit irgendwie über zehn prozent das halt.
Klar ist dass in italien die dunkelziffer viel viel höher ist als in deutschland also es war schon klar dass in italien die dunkelziffer vier bis fünf mal so hoch war,
wie in deutschland so das war mir schon länger bekannt und ich habe bei frühen.
Dunkelziffer berechnungen habe ich immer so irgendwas auch um die fünf sechs rausgekriegt aber hab dem nicht getraut habe weil ich mir dachte naja
offiziell ist die rede von zwei ist vielleicht ein bisschen mehr aber irgendwie meine fünf oder sechs und wenn dann italien was ich wusste
nochmal so viel höher ist dann muss ja in italien eine dunkelziffer quote von fünfundzwanzig oder oder dreißig oder so und das ist ja völlig absurd
tatsächlich
ist es aber so dass wir wahrscheinlich bei sechs liegen und italien irgendwo bei zwischen fünfzehn und zwanzig mal so viele infizierte hat also bei der dunkelziffer rate insofern passt das alles
ich halte sechs komma fünf für einen ziemlich guten wert und für die null komma acht gibt es eben auch eine reihe studien das passt auch zur heinzberg studie wenn man
bisschen paar faktoren noch drauf rechnet und ja insofern.
Bist du dir da relativ sicher.
Also ich habe ich habe ein gutes gefühl dabei klar ich bin da jetzt kein experte habe ich gucke jetzt so lange auf die zahlen drauf habe so viele unterschiedliche zahlen gehört und sechs komma zwei fünf
ist der wert den ich jetzt einfach mal hier aus posa irgendwann werden wir es hoffentlich wissen
so wie hoch die dunkelziffer war und dann werden wir sehen wie richtig ich lag mit meinen sechs komma zwei fünf wie gesagt variiert aber mit der zeit aber so über jetzt den,
die hauptinfektionsalter phase und im moment zu fliegen wir.
Deine chips liegen auf der sechs komma zwei fünf
genau also zurück zu dem was ich erläutert habe wir haben also jetzt einen weiteren magischen buchstaben eben dieses und wir wollen das erreichen wir nehmen als die bevölkerung wir teilen das erstmal durch die dunkelziffer faktor sechs komma fünf.
Und dann eben durch diese anzahl der fälle in den letzten zwei wochen.
Das ganze wird dann aber wieder multipliziert mit diesem ärgert das heißt darin drückt sich aus wie viele wie viele beschleunigung ist in dem ganzen spaß gerade gibt.
Genau.
Das schlägt natürlich wahnsinnig aus also wie gesagt fall von freising mit faktor einunddreißig aber vielleicht muss ich noch was zu den vierzehn tagen
sagen die vierzehn tage habe ich einfach erst mal hatte ich die daten,
schon einfach in der tabelle vorliegen sodass sich einfach damit rechnet aber.
Also sind jetzt die daten die welt gesammelt haben sozusagen also mehr wäre jetzt auch erstmal gar nicht gegangen aber es hat trotzdem interessante größe wir wollen ja vergleichen und es ist klar wir müssen mindestens auf eine woche blicken um einfach schwankungen rauszufiltern.
Mindestens auf eine woche müssen wir blicken aber er war jetzt auch nicht
e in die vergangenheit zurückblicken weil normalerweise ist es so also was man bisher weiß vom verlauf dass die leute so sich infizieren so dann,
zweiten
oder dritten tag der infektion schon ziemlich ansteckend sein könnten im schnitt am fünften tag dann symptome entwickeln
und dann natürlich noch weiter ansteckend sind aber in der regel maximal eine woche manchmal auch nur ein paar tage manche leute.
Deutlich länger aber im schnitt eine woche ungefähr so das heißt man kann sagen zwischen die jetzt infektion und dann wie lange die leute anstecken.
Sind man sagen wenn man einfach die,
infizierten der letzten zwei wochen nimmt dann ist das eine gute richtschnur für die zahl der infizierten
ist ein,
bisschen vielleicht auf der hohen seite aber ja ist jedenfalls nicht nicht völlig falsch.
Das ganze ist ja auch nur ein versuch das ganze ist ja versuche überhaupt erstmal greifbar als zu machen was passiert und wo ist dein sieht's schlimmer aus.
Und wo ist es auch offensichtlich gerade überhaupt nicht schlimm
außerdem wurde ja gerade sagst wir wollen es nicht beliebig in die vergangenheit schon wir wollen eigentlich gar nicht nur vergangenheit schauen wir wollen ja eigentlich in die zukunft schauen und vor allem diese aussage dieses
ja also dieses wie viele leute muss ich durch küssen bis ich irgendwie den zombie gefunden habe,
sagt ja auch was über ansteckende aus also man will ja auch quasi den aktuellen zustand in gewisser hinsicht ab.
Den leute sind ja nicht dauerhaft ansteckend aber diese summierung dadurch dass man sich zwei wochen anschaut.
Gewinnt man ja im prinzip auch eben so ein zeitraum der ja auch.
Heute nochmal über contact tracing reden ja auch da geht es immer um diese zwei wochen zeiträume das ist so ein bisschen der bereich in dem sich die sachen halt einfach abspielen.
Und wir sozusagen wir interpol ihren sozusagen für den risiko wert einfach linear die veränderung der von der einen woche zur anderen so das heißt bei dem
jetzt wenn da jetzt so ein irrsinniger wert halt von einunddreißig ist dann geht
die risiko wertberechnung davon aus dass sich das in der nächsten woche nochmal für dreißigfachen
was natürlich nicht passieren wird dass es definitiv stimmt so nicht
aber es ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen ich meine wer sagt mir wenn jetzt in einer woche vorher war einer da jetzt sind einunddreißig da wer sagt mir dass sitzt nicht nächste woche neunhundert da sind,
gehe ich nicht von aus aber wie gesagt
der risiko wert ist eher auf der sicheren seite und ich sage mir wenn sich der wert in einer woche für einen dreißigfachen kann kann er sich in der nächsten woche wieder vereinen und das ist sozusagen die denke dahinter.
Hört ihr natürlich nicht tun.
Weil gut letztlich ist es weil wir halt mit kleinen zahlen zu tun haben wenn wir irgendwie mit nur einem fall in der vorletzten woche zu tun haben klar denn.
So
Lass mir doch mal kurz an der stelle.
Dein ampelsystem erklärt also die zahlen sind rot
gelb oder grün rot heißt zahl ist zu hoch und es müssen dringend maßnahmen getroffen werden um sie zu senken gelb heißt zahl ist zu hoch um zu tagesordnung zurückzukehren grün als zahl ist in ordnung.
Aber wir haben ja nicht nur eine normale ampel sondern wir haben hier eine super ampel und ein super ampel hat halt nochmal ein extra rot und extra grün
das extra grün heißt einheimische da können völlig entspannt sein wenn sie kein ungeschützten kontakt mit fremden aus anderen kreisen hätten empfehlung da bleiben und niemanden reinlassen.
Rot,
hinterlegt lastet eine hoffnung fahren die situation ist praktisch außer kontrolle kürzlich da war und und geschützte kontakte hatte mein name wahrscheinlichkeit von eins zu infiziert empfehlung möglichst zu hause bleiben und außer haus,
mögliche schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen gegen weiträumig meiden das liest kein tourismusverband gerne.
Nein man muss es.
Mein man sieht auch schon bisschen aus der formulierung es ist mit ein bisschen grain of soul zu lesen ja wobei es ist halt es richtet sich halt eher an.
Eher sagen als.
Oder es es richtet sich halt eher an vorsichtige leute ja es ist sagen er also auf der sicheren seite die ganze.
Berechnung so weil,
also die tabelle ist so wenn hier grün nur sagen wenn hier leuchtendes grün also grün hinterlegt ist wenn hier super grün ist so.
Schauen wir doch mal ich drehe mal die tabelle mal gerade mal um wer denn sozusagen hier die spitzenreiter von hinten sind da haben wir also jetzt gerade landkreis wesermarsch ganz weit vorne.
Aber auch cottbus ganz vorne keine fälle in der letzten woche keine fälle in der vorletzten woche die letzte meldung die überhaupt irgendwas gebracht hat ist schon einen monat her.
Also seit einem monat keine fälle nichts überall nullen.
Und das ist sozusagen auch das das also ich hatte ganz viele momente beim rumspielen mit der tabelle und ich kann jedem nur in meinen tabellen sind zwar eigentlich irgendwie drögeres zeug und viele zahlen und so
aber es ist einfach toll zu sehen ja hier mit einem klick okay landkreis wesermarsch seit einunddreißig tagen cockpit frei
so
Größere städte auch schwerin seit neunzehn tagen.
Suhl seit sechsundzwanzig tagen trier immerhin seit dreizehn tagen.
Beziehungsweise ja ja also in der vorletzten woche gab es noch zwei fälle dort ja und.
Seit elf tagen.
Also es ist auch und obwohl die tabelle hier wirklich wirklich gewichtet ist hinzu vorsicht also eher sagen.
Ist es pessimistischer sehen wir hier verdammt viel mehr super grün als super rot.
Und das finde ich ist doch auch schon mal eigentlich toll.
Fast ein viertel fast ein viertel ist super grün bisschen bisschen weniger als ein viertel.
Man kann ja auch jetzt auch schön sortieren also man kann zum beispiel auch nach der einwohnerzahl sortieren und sich mal wirklich auch die ganz großen orte anschauen wie es denn da so steht und es gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also ja also man kann hier wirklich sich schön drin verlieren und es zeigt eben auch
vieles gut weniges ist wirklich schlimm also ich weiß nicht richtig aufgezählten hast du es jetzt nicht die landkreise die hier
besonderen warnmeldung unterliegen als er sich mehr als zwanzig fünfundzwanzig vielleicht ne.
Ja
Man muss man muss auf jeden fall dazu sagen das ganze ist nach wie vor work and progress und buchs,
gut beendet so also es spricht jetzt noch keine große wahrheiten außer wir würden euch auch bitten euch das mal anzuschauen.
Ein paar leute haben das auch schon getan und haben auch schon ein paar bucks gefunden da sind bestimmt auch noch ein paar drin.
Irgendwelche käse oder falsch regierten daten oder so am besten ihr schaut einfach mal euren landkreis nach.
Dann verteilt sich das glaube ich ganz gut weil wir haben ja hörer überall in der republik und darüber hinaus
und checkt doch mal ob ob das irgendwie den realitäten entspricht.
Und ob da richtig gerechnet wurde und so weiter und dann kriegen wir allerdings vielleicht auch so in den nächsten tagen zumindest soweit solides genau das tut was es zumindest verspricht zu tun vielleicht haben wir noch mal ein bisschen was diese aussagekraft an sich sagen also
hier geht es eher darum man gefühl zu bekommen.
Und vor allem eine vergleichbarkeit zu bekommen weil wie du ja eingangs schon sagtest dieses tool vom
naja anzusehen und immer diese maps und wo ist denn der landkreis und so ja alles schön und gut aber man man will ja auch irgendwie mal,
einschätzen können wie viel action muss denn gemacht werden und wenn ich jetzt in so einem landkreis leben würde wo jetzt hier irgendwie alles hoch rot ist.
Naja dann sollte man sich vielleicht mal informieren was eigentlich gerade so geschieht so also.
Deckt sich das mit den
mit den lokal mit der lokalen berichterstattung ja also ich hatte das auch schon den fall paar leute haben dann mal so in ihrem landkreis nachgeschaut und da war dann irgendwie so hier mega steigerung und so und dann kurz mal nachgeholt und dann so ja okay hier alles klar,
fall im altenheim wieder mal zwanzig dazugekommen deswegen sind die zahlen da explodiert so aber wenn das sozusagen aus dem nichts kommt dann muss man sich auch fragen was was denn eigentlich jetzt gerade los ist.
Schöne arbeit pavel ist denke das werden wir nächste woche noch mal so ein bisschen analysieren was es denn uns eigentlich so gesagt hat wie gesagt das ding wird täglich aktualisiert
es ist jetzt nicht immer nur von woche zu woche aussagekräftig sondern jeden tag gibt's eine änderung und jeden tag kann man in diesem ranking hoch und runtergehen also.
Pavel sucht den landkreis superstar und werden jetzt hier sozusagen am besten abschneidet.
Ja also im moment ist es so noch zu der zu der aktualisierung
aktualisiere es im moment die die daten noch von hand also stoß den prozess von hand an meistens gegen mittag die neuen daten kommen so um drei uhr nachts,
irgendwann aber so ich habe das noch nicht automatisiert weil ich auch gerade noch so viele abdaten mache und mich erstmal drauf fokussieren will das ganze,
in der endversion oder eine version die dann auch erstmal so bleiben kann eine weile die dann,
zumindest wo wo dann die macken einigermaßen alle raus sind so
und ein paar gut ein paar features sicherlich also.
Komm komm auch dazu aber ich finde es ist so schon in dem zustand wie es jetzt ist
ist es eine super interessante möglichkeit sich einen überblick zu verschaffen was sich in ganz deutschland tut und dabei ganz schnell auf jeden einzelnen landkreis zugucken und
die miteinander zu vergleichen und zu filtern und städte gegen dies und das und ja.
Was ich noch vorhab ist ich wollte auch noch die bundesländer mit einbauen dass man sehen kann wo die relativ zueinander dass die da auch mit in der liste rangieren und noch ein paar andere dinge so tool-tipps und ein bisschen.
Soviel zu den landkreisen wir hatten auch noch versprochen letzte woche dass wir uns diese woche mal länder anschauen wollen und hatten sie auch schon ein paar länder und in der gruppen rausgesucht wo wir das mal tun wollten aber das ist jetzt alles so ein bisschen in diesem ganzen landkreis dingen untergegangen und dann war da die zeit nicht mehr
da wirklich mal genauer auf die zahlen drauf zu schauen auf jeden fall wollen wir mal so ein bisschen die alten hotspots
anschauen spanien und italien
wäre natürlich da vor allem zu nennen wir wollen natürlich auch mal in die schweiz und österreich schauen weil es jetzt hier einfach auch ein bisschen reichweite von ukw sind auch schon verschiedene nachfragen und hinweise kam wenn ihr da auch erkenntnisse habt zu schweiz und österreich können uns das ja vielleicht einfach mal in die kommentare mal schicken wo es da interessante quellen gibt
datenquellen ja vielleicht gibt's ja auch was vergleichbares
zu unserem landkreis daten wäre auch interessant dann wollen wir natürlich nochmal konkret auf die usa und schauen weil ich.
Das sind so die länder die man abgesehen jetzt von brasilien am meisten auch darunter leiden dass ihr einfach gerade so das funktionale regierungen haben und natürlich auch schweden und niederlande nochmal genau anschauen weil die ja interessant sind in europa sehr zumindest für eine bestimmte zeit
ein anderes konzept gefahren haben als der rest um mal zu gucken was ist denn damit nun wirklich auf sich hat aber seht es uns nach dafür war jetzt einfach
keine zeit.
Ich wollte auch einfach mal die daten all dieser länder so ins mein georg gebracht
tool geben dass ich dort auch vergleichbare verläufe habe und das auf einen blick dann sehen kann und dann wäre da auch qualifiziert was zu sagen können,
sieht es uns nach.
Dafür haben wir den blick auf die landkreise auf eine art und weise ermöglicht der ich glaube ganz hilfreich sein kann.
Gut dann kommen wir zu dem dressing teil den traditionellen denn da hat sich auch einiges getan wie glaube ich schon erwähnt saß er danach aus als ob der sich gar nicht so viel tut aber.
Mittlerweile hat sich doch einiges getan.
Rund um die diskussion um dressing apps gab's auch noch einiges feedback und auch einige diskussionen auf twitter und was ich halt auch immer wieder.
Interessant finde es wie diese aufregung existiert
um die wertigkeit eines solchen systems und speziell eben auch der volkssport die ja so in technik kreisen immer so alarmistische gesehen wird als fehler so und wir hatten ja da auch schon drüber gesprochen.
Dass das ja auch positiven effekt haben kann so ja tests werden häufiger gemacht über test haben wir ja auch schon gesprochen natürlich gilt auch so ein einwand wie ja wenn jetzt irgendjemand,
was ich jede woche als positiv gemeldet wird und dann war immer nichts dann ist natürlich auch nicht gut klar ist so.
Also derzeit gibt es diese diese wahrnehmung,
das passiv bedeutet hat nicht den virus so aber dafür ist dieses ganze protokoll diese exporter notification eigentlich nicht
gebaut sondern was es halt eigentlich bedeutet man kriegt halt eine mitteilung darüber dass man einer positiv getesteten person.
Ausgesetzt war das ist ja das was irgendwie drinsteckt und das über einen nennenswerten zeitraum von dem man annimmt dass er möglicherweise kritisch eingeordnet ist so und das ist halt.
Kein volk positiv in dem sinne sondern das ist einfach fakt das du warst dem ausgesetzt.
Das ob das was bedeutet ist nochmal eine ganz andere frage wir liefern ja einfach ein fakt an dieser stelle.
Im moment ist es ja auch so dass wenn du einen kontakt hattest zu jemandem der positiv getestet war wirst du ja auch darüber auf anderen wegen,
benachrichtigt wenn du bekannt bist und diese app soll ja nur die lücke schließen für die,
wenigen fälle wo es halt nicht bekannt ist oder wir wissen nicht wie viele es sind aber ich denke so was ich höre wie die schwellenwertes jetzt so wahrscheinlich gesetzt werden wird es nicht allzu viele
warnmeldungen geben zu maja auch nicht so viele leute erkranken.
Genau wer soll sowieso mit niedrigen zahlen zu tun haben und ohnehin auch noch eine weile dauern wird bis eben diese app überhaupt ihre kraft entwickeln kann wenn wenn wir überhaupt an diesen punkt kommen.
Dass man nur vorweg.
Die eigentliche neuigkeit ist die deutsche corona tracing support ich nenne das immer ganz gerne so diese app die also jetzt alle unsere probleme lösen soll.
Existiert jetzt vor allem hat sie einen namen und sie hört auf den rumreichen und klangvollen namen corona waren.
An diesem namen ist glaube ich alles falsch was man irgendwie nur falsch machen kann
aber vielleicht folgt es auch irgendwie einer logik die ich nicht so nachfolgen kann und die auch okay ist ja also irgendjemand wird sich darüber gedanken gemacht haben und beschlossen haben,
das soll sie nun mal so sein ja vielleicht nennen wir sie einfach nur c.
Was so ein bisschen die abkürzung ist die sich jetzt hier auch in der dokumentation in urls und so weiter niederschlägt aber ich finde er deutschland hat eigentlich gar nicht so eine schlechte tradition mit solchen namen.
Was ich ja immer noch am am am geilsten finde ist ja elster.
Dass das dass das protokoll und die website zum einreichen der steuererklärung und ich finde wer auch immer sich das hat einfallen lassen.
Hat humor bewiesen und irgendjemand ohne humor hat es nicht verhindert und das finde ich eigentlich schon mal eine leistung an der stelle hätte man sich vielleicht auch daran orientieren können aber ist nun mal nicht so.
Also warn-app das ganze wird ja von sap in zusammenarbeit mit der telekom entwickelt.
Konkret sieht es so aus dass sap tatsächlich diese.
Eigentliche software struktur baut die zuständig ist für die telefone also die eigentliche.
Und das zugehörige backend beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich verschiedene komponenten eines backend und soweit ich das gehört habe,
greift die telekom mit zusätzlicher infrastruktur dauert
ein ich vermute auch mit einer infrastruktur die es unter umständen schon gibt wir hatten ja auch schon mal erwähnt telekom ist mit ihrer mit ihrem herz department da auch schon unterwegs.
Besondere in dieser ganzen testing infrastruktur von daher gehe ich davon aus dass die telekom.
Mit ihrer spate dort den bereich abdeckt der diese ganzen labore miteinander verbindet also dort
quasi infrastruktur im backend hat und dass eben all die ganze zusätzliche infrastruktur die jetzt erforderlich ist um das mit dieser tracing app zu verbinden von sap kommt und dass die sich dort an irgendeiner stelle
treffen und das miteinander verbinden.
Gesehen von dem namen gibt es auch schon eine allererste dokumentation das ist jetzt noch recht spärlich ist mehr so eine art,
ja so software-engineering,
planen das ist das was bisher veröffentlicht wurde allerdings gibt's da schon ein paar ganz interessante informationen dadrin zunächst einmal,
soll das alles unter apatsche zwei null dezenz also unter einer extrem liberalen open source dezenz veröffentlicht werden.
Konkret bedeutet dass es nicht nur open source ist im sinne von man kann jetzt mal reinschauen sondern es ist halt code der dort entsteht den kann man danach einfach nehmen und benutzen.
Ob man das für irgendwas benutzen kann oder will steht erstmal vollkommen außer frage also innerhalb von deutschland macht's natürlich relativ wenig sinn
aber andere länder könnten sich zum beispiel eben auch dieses kurz bemächtigen und den für eigene software projekte nutzen das finde ich schon mal ganz gut.
Und die zweite interessante information ist dass abgesehen von diesem ganzen tracing was wir hier schon in länglicher ausführung mehrfach den berg rauf und wieder runter gerollt haben tatsächlich eben wie vermutet auch dieses
testing mit in diese app integriert wird also wenn ich diese app installiert habe.
Dann bin ich in der lage dass wenn ich jetzt ein corona virus test mache.
Mir die ergebnis mitteilung auf dem telefon zu stellen zu lassen.
Also in irgendeiner form wird es da ein mechanismus geben da ist so von q codes die rede.
Dass man also ich vermute mal wenn man also jetzt da irgendwo zu einem labor geht oder war seinem arzt also irgendeiner form mit diesem prozess in verbindung kommt dass man dann dort.
Einen code erhält den dann quasi mit seiner app scannt und dann weiß dass
hat das telefon sozusagen so eine referenz auf diesen test und kann dann eben über diese infrastruktur nachfragen was ist denn jetzt mit meinem test oder anders ausgedrückt dieses backend ist in der lage mir eine mitteilung zukommen zu lassen.
Auf welchem weg auch immer also es müsste noch nicht mal eine push-notification sein sondern hier funktioniert ja ohnehin alles immer über regelmäßige downloads also diese app ist ohnehin mehr oder weniger regelmäßig mit diesem backend ja in verbindung und könnte darüber auch zugespielt,
bekommen so übrigens hier tests ist verfügbar.
Kannst du kannst du dir jetzt runterladen und dann dann erhalte ich quasi die nachricht direkt auf mein.
Telefon und kann dort sehen so hier ergebnis deines tests so sieht's aus was ganz sinnvoll ist.
War ja dann der nächste schritt im prinzip der ist dass du gebeten wirst so.
Jetzt bisher mit der app die ganze zeit rumgelaufen dein telefon hat bluetooth all dies getauscht mit anderen leuten jetzt wollen wir nochmal schauen wie sieht's denn aus so und jetzt möchten wir eben diese diese kies haben,
von dir,
die du quasi durch die weltgeschichte geblasen hast damit wir den anderen telefon zu leiten können damit die gucken können ob sie mit dir in kontakt warten.
Und ja das das scheint also diese infrastruktur die jetzt hier gebaut wird tatsächlich zu machen.
Ja soweit so unüberlegt also das ist eigentlich das womit ich eigentlich auch gerechnet habe dass das hat sich
meiner meinung nach schon abgezeichnet durch die entsprechenden projektpartner und was bisher so schon so durchgesickert ist und ich gehe davon
aus dass wir jetzt wohl auch in nächster zeit dann auch langsam mal kot sehen werden oder zumindest erstmal mehr dokumentation wie das so genau funktioniert was sie sich da jetzt für ein modell ausgedacht haben
welche kryptografisch verfahren da zum einsatz kommen welcher teile wann wo was sieht damit man eben auch
eine informierte abschätzung machen kann darüber wie
sehr das versprechen des schutzes der privatsphäre und datenschutz und so weiter dort auch eingehalten werden kann ja.
Corona warn-app demnächst auf ihrem telefon.
Ich.
Tendiere dazu unfreiwillig immer wenn ich irgendwas höre so in die zukunft zu extra polieren
wo du jetzt erzählt hast und ich mir auch dabei mal die speck angesehen habe diese journey und übersicht der epics also sie machen da offenbar so eine art scrum
prozess stories und so weiter ich erinnere mich dass ich vor zwanzig jahren angefangen habe
damals mit extremprogramming und agile prozesse
einzuführen und ja welchen weiten weg des seitdem genommen hat ja.
Da haben wir übrigens mal einen podcast so aufgenommen falls sich da.
Ja stimmt das ist auch her sein und ich muss.
Das ist e her ich habe gerade mal nachgeschaut das ist auf heute fast auf den tag genau vierzehn jahre her.
Vierzehn jahre.
Nee insofern sei mal ist jetzt weil sie herangehensweise finde ich jetzt erstmal okay,
es muss muss halt auch einigermaßen schnell gehen und trotzdem muss man natürlich irgendwie einsammeln was denn der auftraggeber eigentlich haben will weil am ende ist es
derjenige der das in auftrag gibt und die bundesregierung die dafür bezahlt und die wollen natürlich auch irgendwie wissen was sie denn kriegen
in etwa und die leute die es machen sollen wollen natürlich ein bisschen genauer wissen was hier jetzt eigentlich machen sollen und ich halte das
durchaus auch für vernünftig und im sinne jetzt von extra polieren in die zukunft ich hoffe dass ja corona.
Bald geschichte sein wird oder sag mal so diese oder cobic neunzehn
dass wir hoffentlich ja im herbst kein neuaufbruch kriegen und das ganze jetzt so in den in den griff kriegen aber
erstens vielleicht ist die hoffnung dazu verfrüht so weil alle experten gehen davon aus
dass es halt im herbst dann interessant werden könnte weil definitiv jetzt bei den zahlen die wir jetzt haben macht es fast schon keinen sinn mehr.
So die.
Die warn-app also weil es so ausgedünnt ist in der in der fläche und und so vielleicht in ein paar großstädten aber aber,
erstens kannst wiederkommen und zweitens um noch weiter in die zukunft muss es erstens nicht die.
Einzige derart gefährliche krankheit bleiben und es gibt halt auch noch andere meldepflichtig krankheiten insofern sehe ich schon so ein bisschen die vision also das schöne dass das ganze jetzt so privatsphäre schont,
ist dass man dann auch überlegen kann ob man das nicht auch nach ko.
Sagen beibehält und das ganze in eine allgemeine exposé notification app.
Für ja meldepflichtig krankheiten für ansteckende krankheiten gemacht wird weil.
Der prozess ist nämlich bei den gesundheitsämtern für meldepflichtig krankheiten für andere mehr oder weniger der gleiche wenn jemand weiß ich nicht an masern oder rütteln oder keuchhusten oder was ist da nicht nicht alles
gibt noch
und da das ganze jetzt auch globale verbreitung findet könnte so eine app dann auch wenn sie uns vielleicht jetzt unmittelbar nicht hilft aber
auf dauer tatsächlich doch noch mal einen echten vorteil in der bekämpfung meldepflichtig krankheiten und infektionen und pandemien und so allgemein
zu
Bieten das ist halt einfach zu jedem telefon dazu gehört dass wir das dass wir dann halt wissen okay also wie siehst du das.
Ja also ich denke dass niemand derzeit das schon so versucht zu pushen.
Apple hat ja auch apple und google zusammen haben gesagt,
ja das ist jetzt erstmal ein sonderfall das ist ja jetzt auch explizit auf die ausbreitung von copic neunzehn festgelegt ne auch wenn es natürlich so ist wie du sagst dass hier
eigentlich in dem protokoll überhaupt nichts spezifisches drin ist,
mit der ausnahme dass wir es hier mit so einem festen zeitraum von vierzehn tagen zu tun haben nachdem dann die kies auch wieder weggeschmissen werden also wenn wir jetzt irgendeiner form ein virus haben der einen längeren zeitraum.
Aktiv und gefährlich ist dann müsste das an der stelle auch schon wieder angepasst werden was natürlich dann
technisch überhaupt gar kein problem ist und man muss das hier auch grundsätzlich generalisieren also ich stimme dazu dass es möglich wäre wie die akzeptanz ist weiß ich nicht aber da die technik erstmal da ist,
könnte man selbst wenn jetzt alles abgeschaltet es geht ja nicht darum dass jetzt
alle sollen jetzt immer beacons aussenden und export notification permanent tracken für den fall dass was losgeht darum geht's nicht sondern es geht darum dass wenn wir wieder so ein notfall erkennen und sagen okay ab jetzt haben wir wieder ein problem
bitte bitte bitte schaltet mal alle hier ladet mal die aktuelle app runter und dann gibt's vielleicht auch global nur noch eine einzige und dann macht man den schalter an dann.
Können wir das problem vielleicht jetzt schon sehr schnell in griff kriegen aber das ist wirklich zukunftsmusik,
vielleicht mal einen blick darauf was ich jetzt konkret auch daraus ergibt also diese corona warn-app.
Nehmen wir mal an also ich gehe davon aus dass existiert jetzt schon viel code ich gehe davon aus dass diese eigentliche app selber da ist.
Die ist noch nicht fertig da funktioniert wahrscheinlich noch nicht alles so,
aber ich werde jetzt nicht so er rascht ich habe keine genauen erkenntnisse darüber ist jetzt so ein bisschen mein gefühl achtzig prozent läuft ja
im backend vielleicht noch ein paar mehr baustellen und so aber die arbeiten jetzt mit hochdruck darauf hin das system an sich zum laufen zu bringen und wir haben ja auch schon mehrfach
die komplexität ist insgesamt überschaubar das ist jetzt kein
hexenwerk sonst musst du im wesentlichen nur richtig spezifiziert und dann richtig runter programmiert werden und wir nähern uns auch diesen zeitpunkt wo das eigentliche release stattfindet.
Ich habe.
Mir auch nochmal einen ein längeres panel so ein online-handel angeschaut ist schon ein bisschen älter das ist vom vierundzwanzigsten april das hatte ich schon länger auf meiner liste aber das war so lange und ich wusste habe einfach die zeit nicht gefunden
war ganz interessant es war nämlich ein
so quasi so eine so ein so eine online-sitzungen eine öffentliche form europäischen parlament wo zugeschaut haben oder wer auch sonst immer noch interesse hat wo es eben um diese ganze dressing geschichte und das digitale ging.
Wo diverse experten sich,
zu gemeldet hat das war dann so verschiedene panels eingeteilt das zweite panel wendete sich dann eben ganz konkret um diese implementierung so das war ganz interessant also erstmal diese.
Wie lange gegen das insgesamt.
Naja also insgesamt ist es glaube ich so eine so eine zweieinhalb stunden geschichte aber dieses panel selber ist glaube ich nur so dreiviertel stunde oder so
kann man sich also schon nochmal anschauen war ganz interessant interessant vor allem weil es einerseits um diese ganze zentral dezentral debatte noch ein bisschen ging und auch
grundsätzlich um diese ansätze privatsphäre etcetera datenschutz all das wurde dort diskutiert und dieses zweite panel war dann aber eben unter konkreter beteiligung
von einerseits diesem michael will das entwickler von diesem auch auf twitter sehr.
Umtriebig unterwegs ist und der vor allem auch diese ganzen security einschätzung und preis die einschätzung geschrieben hat nicht zum teil ja auch vorgetragen habe also unter anderem diese security analyse und preis die analyse von diesem zentralen
protokoll was ich hier mal ausführlich vorgestellt habe oder wo ich zumindest aspekte rausgenommen habe was sozusagen dort
das problem ist das war von ihm geschrieben oder zumindest einen großen teil von ihm geschrieben.
Dann noch ein vertreter von apple gary davis der dort für privacy und love and forth zuständig ist
merkt man mal was so die abwehr
auch sind und der ist so weiß präsident vor engineering also google hat im prinzip ein ingenieur geschrieben und so haben sie dann auch verschiedenste aspekte.
Abgedeckt ja das war ganz
aufschlussreich mal mit anzusehen wie apple und google da auch argumentieren und auf welche argumente sie da auch antworten hatten oder wo sie auch lieber nichts zugesagt haben
dabei kam dann auch noch eine information raus wo denn dieses dieses system schnittstelle jetzt verfügbar gemacht werden sollen haben wir auch lange darüber gerätselt,
war es dann auch ganz konkret hatte ich bloß zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht mitbekommen wir werden also sehen dass.
Google das tatsächlich über diese play service wie vermutet ausrollen wird und tatsächlich vorhat das bis android sechs zurück.
Unterstützen mit anderen worten viele viele jahre zurück also auch sehr alte andré telefone werden die gelegenheit haben diese schnittstelle zu nutzen
und das ist auch relativ wichtig weil wir wissen ja aber android ist dass du mit der adoption der neueren betriebssysteme version so eine sache das dauert immer eine eine weile während sie aber apple ein bisschen anders aussieht da ist der großteil der telefone auf dem aktuellen betriebssystem
und tatsächlich plant apple wohl bisher nur für das aktuelle dreizehn.
Ein update zu bringen wo man ja denken kann so aber was ist denn mit den anderen telefon.
Das ding ist im januar war es so dass eiweiß dreizehn auf.
Siebzig prozent aller telefone war und auf so siebenundsiebzig prozent aller telefone den letzten vier jahren.
Gekauft wurden.
Iphone sechs noch dabei eigentlich oder nicht mehr also sechser ist rausgefallen jetzt.
Sex ist rausgefallen ja also ich glaube die grenze ist jetzt sechs oder sieben.
Und natürlich geht das spiel ja am laufenden meter weiter also ich habe so den eindruck apple sagt sich naja also die adoption also wenn jetzt.
Das problem sind ja leute die nicht updaten aber leute die nicht updaten die updaten auch eben nicht auf das
aller aktuellste betriebssystem obwohl sie es könnten also wenn sie das tun dann gehen sie sowieso schon auf dreizehn das heißt diese zahl wird noch steigen wenn man sie also anschaut wie groß ist die story base von telefon die theoretisch updaten könnten,
ja und die vielleicht dann eben auch dadurch dafür motiviert werden könnten dann kommt man eben schon sehr schnell in so einem fünfundachtzig prozent bereich rein,
aktuellere zahlen als januar gibt es bisher nicht das ist das was so vermutlich vermutet hat aber damit machen sie es natürlich auch den entwicklern einfacher weil das bedeutet die müssen dann eben mit dieser app auch nur,
ein tages und brauchen nicht noch rückwärts kompatibilität aufrecht zu erhalten ist vielleicht ein.
Kein großes problem aber so ist es eben jetzt naja.
Jetzt gab es auch nochmal ein update also das diese diese dieses framework ist,
bei apple und ruhiger und entwicklung und ich weiß es nicht ganz genau was auf der anrede welt passiert ist aber bei
apple hatte ich ja schon gesagt gab es eine bittere version wo das drin war da gab es eine neue version und da gab's dann auch noch ein paar interessante änderungen.
Nämlich einerseits war haben sie jetzt dann doch auf ein reines opt-in modell umgeschaltet ich hatte ja gesagt so dieses eigentliche betreiben des protokoll s.
Das läuft dann schon machst es dann ist es an.
Das war wohl so in dieser bittere version haben sie jetzt geändert jetzt ist es so dass erst wenn du die app installiert kannst du überhaupt erst alles anschalten vermute mal dass eine politische entscheidung.
Technisch hätte ich jetzt nicht not getan gut wenn man sehen wie es am ende rauskommt aber so zeichnet sich derzeit.
Was ich jetzt auch noch gehört habe ist dass das aber nicht.
Alles zu sein scheint also abgesehen davon dass sie dieses feuerwerk und dieser api und dieses protokoll dieses spezifikation vorantreiben.
Leute das irgendwie im busch das wort google und apple auch noch an mehr arbeiten.
Und wir hatten ja hier auch im zusammenhang mit diesem hinweis die sie ja von anfang an gegeben haben dass sie
lädt das irgendwie in ihre systeme einbauen wollen so ein bisschen gerätselt und gemutmaßt und ein bisschen glaskugel was bist denn das jetzt bedeuten könnte.
Ich hatte mich da ein bisschen aus dem fenster gelehnt abgesagt so naja was was ich hier was ist mit ländern die sich gar keine infrastruktur leisten können sowie das modell funktioniert könnte im prinzip ja,
könnten die beiden das für die länder auch noch übernehmen ohne irgendeiner form die privatsphäre jetzt weiter zu gefährden also es ist ja in diesem dezentralen modell.
Sind einfach die kritischen daten auf dem telefon und wer da jetzt das backend betreibt eigentlich egal also das funktioniert dann entweder nur oder es funktioniert nicht die einzige kritische komponente ist das woran halt jetzt,
und telekom eben arbeiten das eben mit diesen ganzen laboren und so weiter zu integrieren.
Auf der einen seite auf der anderen seite und das scheint jetzt so ein bisschen die gerüchte lage zu sein ist alles bestätigt noch.
Absoluter busch funk aber das jetzt hier irgendeiner form an protokollen schemas und solchen public infrastrukturen gearbeitet wird im hinblick auf roaming.
Also die grundsätzliche problematik ist ja wenn wir jetzt so eine app haben und die in deutschland starten und.
Hier werden sozusagen diese diese diagnosen ausgetauscht dann ist das ja alles total super solange wir noch unter uns sind und alle grenzen sind geschlossen.
Ja aber was es eben wenn es wirklich losgeht mit dem urlaub was ist wenn leute wieder über die grenzen kommen dürfen wenn pendler unterwegs sind wenn urlaub gemacht wird wenn geschäftsreisen wieder gefahren bin einfach diese internationalität wieder stattfindet
dann wollen wir ja auch in irgendeiner form verbindung schaffen und offensichtlich findet dort auch arbeit statt ich.
Gehe halt nach wie vor davon aus dass wir am ende dieser saga schon auch eine globale föderation all dieser ganzen daten haben werden einfach weil es total.
Sinnvoll ist aber es bleibt schwierig,
wir haben ja diese auseinandersetzung in deutschland um dezentral und zentral gesehen das ist ja sehr positiv dann ausgegangen
wir haben das dezentrale modell schweiz österreich haben sich die modell angeschlossen istland hat sich dem modell angeschlossen und ich glaube auch irland und noch ein paar andere.
Und gibt aber auch welche die sind hartnäckig einerseits frankreich.
In ihrer zentralistischen tradition.
Habe ich mir fast schon gedacht so.
Ja die sind da ja auch immer noch extrem bockig.
Zentral und die franzosen es geht irgendwie so gar nicht zusammen.
Genau und wer sich auch schwer tut und das können wir glaube ich auch ganz gut nachfühlen es polen.
Also auch da gibt es wohl widerstand dagegen hab jetzt nicht so den mega überblick über die ganze eu aber ich würde mal sagen also ich glaube ist auch schon mit im boot und
glaube spanien kriegst gerade nicht zusammen also.
Es entwickelt sich so die front bröckelt auf jeden fall ein weiterer interessanter vertreter eines zentralen modells und den wollte ich jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen genauer vorstellen.
Ist wie könnte es anders sein ja ein land oder vielleicht überhaupt das land gerade in europa mit,
den allergrößten probleme mit dieser ganzen krankheit was jetzt auch ähnlich wie die usa schon nach lockerem schreit und die auch schon verkündet hat zu einem zeitpunkt wo man eigentlich nur mit dem kopf schütteln kann.
Ja da sieht's einfach nochmal richtig schön scheiße aus nicht nur viele todesfälle nicht nur schnell steigende oder zumindest nicht nennenswert abnehmende infizierten zahlen
permanent neue skandale sehr schlechte ausrüstung extreme belastung des gesundheitssektor und und und und und und jetzt wollen sie auch noch irgendwie lockern und
test haben sie auch keine also ist eine totale katastrophe aber natürlich haben sie auch so eine tracing app am start und da hat die also dieser national health service auch eine eigene abteilung heißt.
X und die haben auch irgendwie jetzt eine app
entwickelt und wie sollte es anders sein zentrales modell mit den üblichen problemen die wir ja schon tausendfach besprochen haben bitte testen sie gerade auf der i love white
und guck mal was da bei rauskommt
busch funk sagt sieht nicht so gut aus also gibt da wohl diverse probleme der vorher vorhin von mir erwähnte michael will von diesem.
Die drei p projekt hat sich wohl das ding auch schon komplett vorgenommen was da bekannt es gibt da wohl auch schon open source release und sein
urteil ist entsprechend vernichtend was so datenschutz privatsphäre etcetera betrifft wie das eben bei der zentralen modellen generell ist aber es geht wohl auch noch weitere hinaus habe
mir das nicht komplett durchgelesen nur so das summary und das war irgendwie schlimm
aber auch dort wird jetzt schon gemunkelt dass es halt wackelt weil sie natürlich auch alle dieses problem haben dass sie einfach auf iphones nicht vorankommen.
Aber es ist ganz putzig die haben nämlich probiert das zu umgehen kurz nochmal zum hintergrund apple verbietet es apps.
Im hintergrund einfach so bluethoothspeaker einzusammeln und der hintergrund ist ganz klar die wollen halt verhindern.
Dass es gibt die sich bei dir installieren unseren game und dann läuft das ding im hintergrund und sammelt einfach bluethoothspeaker ein
und indem man das macht kann man halt ein sehr gutes location und bewegungstraining machen und das will man halt verhindern also generell
ist so location sammeln im hintergrund ist eingeschränkt und diese umgehung der normalen beschränkung des location sammelns weil es ja nochmal ein extra recht ist dann konnte man die
betriebssystem hoch und sagt ja hier die app die sammelt und wie die location hintergrund willst du das immer noch und so also man hat da verschiedenste möglichkeiten auch später noch automatisch gewarnt zu werden und wenn er sie jetzt bluetooth im hintergrund einfach so laufen würde hätte man das ja quasi umgegangen.
Und deswegen geht das halt nicht und das ist natürlich jetzt gerade für dieses contact tracing für diese apps problem technisches problem
und die haben sich dann was ganz pfiffiges einfallen lassen wie sie das umgehen wollen also problem ist wenn du das jetzt machen willst du kannst im vordergrund kannst du das alles sammeln aber wenn du den hintergrund gehst dann wird dann deine app halt irgendwann gekillt
und jetzt machen sie es aber so dass sie quasi von anderen apps entsprechende bluethoothspeaker,
verschicken die dann dazu führen dass diese app dann immer wieder gestartet wird.
Die hat dann irgendwie zehn minuten zeit zu reagieren und so heißt aber auch dass dann quasi mit jeder anfrage immer die app
geladen wird entsprechend viel strom verbraucht das ding geht dann halt schickt dann halt den akku
im keller etcetera läuft auch nicht zuverlässig und so weiter und es auch ehrlich gesagt würde es mich noch nicht mal wundern wenn apple das ist noch in ihrem update irgendwas
release was auch noch diese umtriebe noch weiter einschränkt also summery.
Die haben so ihre probleme und alle anderen modelle beißen sich auf mit der technischen realität ganz gut die zehner daran aus und gerade diese sache mit batterie sparen.
Das ist halt ein echtes ding weil wir reden ja jetzt davon dass besten fall milliarden telefone diese zusatzbeleuchtung bekommen von permanent nachgucken über netz.
Und das ist halt wenn man sich richtig macht eine extreme last.
Für das telefon insbesondere das einsammeln dieser ganzen senden es wohl relativ unproblematisch die sind ja eigentlich am laufenden meter
aber einsammeln tun sie halt nicht also
ich glaube derzeit ist es so dass normalen modus mit dem exporter notification läuft es so dass sie halt alle fünf minuten aufwachen und dann für zwei sekunden lang gucken.
Also diese beacons werden auch am laufenden meter rausgesendet und die werden sich sozusagen auch schon ihre gedanken gemacht haben ob das nun ausreicht oder nicht.
Geh mal davon aus dass es ausreicht weil sonst hätten sie sicherlich was
was anderes genommen so aber das zeigt dann eben schon wie sparsam sie da eigentlich rangehen einfach damit wenn du das ding einschaltest du jetzt nicht auf einmal denkst du oh mann also mein akku hat aber gestern zwei stunden länger gehalten.
Weil dann wird es einfach dazu führen dass die leute sagen ich kriege ich kein ich kriege kein corona.
Weg mit der app ist halt einfach so also wir werden sehen dass da noch einiges,
passiert es gibt beim technology review online auch noch ein kobig tracing tracker den link habe ich meine shownotes gepackt ist na ja noch nicht so ganz,
aktuell aber der enthält zumindest mal den versuch aller alle apps aller länder zu aufzuführen und mal danach zu kategorisieren ob die jetzt zentrales dezentrales modell haben wie das da mit privatsphäre ist ob die gps oder bluetooth verwenden etcetera
ja ich bleibe eigentlich bei meiner einschätzung dass wir über kurz oder lang.
Sehen werden dass dieses dezentrale modell sich in den vordergrund schiebt und dass diese ganzen zentralen apps entweder daran scheitern dass sie.
Technische nicht umsetzbar sind keine akzeptanz finden oder spätestens an der problematik des roaming scheitern werden.
Dass ihr einfach irgendwann einen anschluss haben wollen gibt ja auch viele diskussionen um.
Zwänge und so weiter ob man den leuten das irgendwie vorschreiben kann ich habe da so meine zweifel ob sie sowas durchsetzen wird aber irgendjemand wird es sicherlich probieren und am ende kann man sagen unabhängig von irgendeiner rechtlichen vorgabe.
Ist es halt auch einfach so dass ich mir vorstellen kann dass wir so einen punkt erreichen wo man sich sagt so ja lieber.
Lieber lieber haben so und lieber dann auch an so einem schutzmechanismus teilnehmen können und wenn ich halt.
In ein anderes land fahre dann möchte ich immer noch dass meine nationale app mich warnen kann.
Also nur weil ich jetzt mal eine woche in frankreich bin warum sollte ich denn dann auf einmal diesen indirekten schutz nicht haben also schutz nicht im sinne von ich kriege kein korona weil ich eine app installiert habe sondern.
Schutz im sinne von ich kann gewarnt werden wenn auch nur indirekt
ja weil andere leute gewarnt wurden und ich dann schneller gewarnt werde das ist nicht kriege oder ich hab's vielleicht ja volles prosit aber dann doch nicht aber zumindest nicht gewarnt worden hat einen test bekommen all diese ganzen faktoren die wir schon mehrfach
daran will man halt teilnehmen und dann braucht es eben auch so ein roaming also summa summarum.
In deutschland geht es voran länder mit zentralen modell werden glaube ich so ihre probleme haben man sieht es eben sehr schön.
Und dieses roaming diese internationale austausch von warnmeldungen der gewinnt an fahrt und es sieht sogar so aus als ob apple und google selber hier nochmal.
Was rausbringen werden und wie gesagt wir wissen schon in den letzten sendung besprochen haben.
Meiner meinung nach kann das sogar soweit gehen dass es eben nicht nur roaming ist sondern das war eben sogar in irgendeiner form.
Den kompletten betrieb übernimmt für für andere länder die einfach sagen echt wir haben auch andere sachen zu tun.
Also ich finde es ist nach wie vor den versuch wert auch wenn wir hier schon öfter gesagt haben
die app corona nicht stoppen wird so da müssen wir mehr
für tun und ja selbst wenn's nicht klappen
sollte oder nicht helfen sollte ich denke mal angesichts dessen was sonst so jetzt verloren geht
oder was die ganze sache kostet kann man uns das eigentlich auch noch leisten und ja es kann eigentlich nur helfen
denke ich zu mama ja sieht wie schnell die leute jetzt so zur tagesordnung wieder übergehen teilweise nicht alle.
Ähm ja und ansonsten würde ich sagen sind es für deutschland eher.
Gute nachrichten so gut bis auf den namen wie du schon gesagt hattest aber es ist in deutschen auch schwierig ich meine der name.
Das ist mal so die frage auch wonach suchen die leute oder was also was ok ist ist das halt völlig klar ist worum es sich handelt.
Ein vorschlag von den entwicklern war cora.
Cora.
Ja wobei das dann wohl so ein bisschen wie wie auch bei wirbelstürme und so weiter da war es ja auch lange zeit mal so dass dass dass die stürmer immer nur.
Die tiefs nicht die stürmer also doch die stimme war ja auch nochmal separat benannt aber bei den hochsommer bei den tiefs was ja lange zeit so die hochs das war dann immer männernamen und die tiefs das war dann immer frauennamen so
hat mir dann irgendwann eingestellt und gesagt okay wir wechseln das jetzt immer ab und dann ist da.
Auch egal ob da einfach diesen sexistischen bayers dabei herauszubekommen und wahrscheinlich hatte man jetzt hier sozusagen auch angst mit so einem namen sowas ähnliches zu induzierten wobei man ja sagen könnte die app hilft ja ne.
Also.
Also ich ich finde wo ich,
den namen wirklich gut fand als ich den gehört habe war der name von der warn-app in singapur trails
ja der hat sowas positives der appelliert irgendwie.
An gemeint an die gemeinschaft an die gemeinsamkeit so aber das englische eignet sich einfach auch viel besser umso snap kurze namen
zu haben im deutschen des deutsches da doch ein bisschen sperriger immer so für gut.
Ja ich meine hast du auch nina installiert die notfall informationen und nachrichten des bundes.
Ich glaube ich habe die katastrophe katwarn genau katwarn.
Das ist waren genau also waren weißt du wer das macht.
Nee.
Das ist finanziert von der deutschen versicherungs- trie.
Ja die haben gesagt so lass mal die leute lieber vorher wissen dass da ein sturm kommt dann können sie mal noch ihre fenster verrammelt wenn das da schon dran glauben muss so.
Also das ist sozusagen auch mit dieser intention von vielleicht bist du da nicht ganz so viel zahlen nina ist wiederum das offizielle die offiziell und wie es auf der webseite auch heißt warn-app nina.
Also dieses waren ding steckt offensichtlich in den behörden sowieso schon drin und jetzt muss halt wieder gewarnt werden jetzt muss halt gewarnt werden vor corona also es ist die korona warn-app,
aber irgendwie also ich weiß nicht die corona warn-app cora hätte jetzt eigentlich auch funktioniert.
Aber wie gesagt vielleicht wollten sie diesen sächsischen beides raus haben die man jetzt so oder so sehen kann habe ich auch verständnis für so aber irgendwie wie willst du denn jetzt den leuten sagen ja hast du die corona warn-app installiert.
Scheiß begriff aber so hast du cora irgendwie das hätte doch echt echt gut funktioniert.
Ja ja sogar also cora finde ich ein bisschen wiederum knapp also dieser tress fand ich eigentlich bisher so geilsten.
Gemeinsam spür.
Naja das funktioniert im.
Im deutschen nicht.
Nein das funktioniert einfach nicht da brauchst du dicke liga abkürzung und dann musst du halt irgendwie auf dem passenden namen bei rauskommen naja so ist es halt wirklich wenn es wahrscheinlich nicht ändern können,
hallo pavel ich glaube wir haben's alles wieder ganz gut zusammengerührt bekommen oder.
Ich denke denke auch eine sache.
Viel mehr noch auf hast du von dem irgendwie angeblich studie gehört.
Die sagen die wirksamkeit von solchen apps in frage stellt grundsätzlich so ist sie da was untergekommen oder.
Studie ne.
Gut können wir vielleicht dann beim nächsten mal gucken ob ich das ding ausgegraben kriege das irgendwas an mir vorbei gescrollt wo angeblich.
Ausgewertet wurde singapur glaube ich auswertung wie das denn in singapur dann mit der traces to app eigentlich gelaufen ist wer vielleicht mal interessant bei uns das mal vielleicht kannst du das ja bis nächste woche herausfinden.
Ich schaue mir das mal an also es gab auch entsprechend negative berichte jetzt von der app in in island.
Island war es dann es war nicht dann nicht singapur sondern island aber singapur wir auch interessant.
Ja wobei da kann man einfach das kann man schnell beantworten der isländische ansatz war mit gps.
Ja
So und warum das eine schlechte idee ist das haben wir hier schon ganz so abfangen ausführlich aus einer.
Ja das hätte man gar nicht probieren brauchen ja.
Genau das hätte man gar nicht erst probieren brauchen von daher ist das so eine sache gibt auch andere studien die auch sagen ja das kann alles irgendwie hinhauen ich sage einfach nur am ende.
Wir müssen es einfach ausprobieren so und dann ja da stirbt keiner dran mit dem dezentralen modell haben wir da wirklich nichts zu verlieren und von daher ist ist das irgendwie alles so ein ding.
Ja und wie gesagt mir gefällt eigentlich die zukunftsperspektive nur sagen einer,
allgemein epidemie kontakt infektionsweg kontakt waren app
vor also ich könnte mir sowas durchaus vorstellen funktioniert natürlich nur wenn das allgemein auf begeisterung und zustimmung stößt und ein großteil der leute damit rumläuft wenn nur fünf prozent,
rumlaufen und natürlich bräuchte es dann auch die zustimmung von google und apple die
ja natürlich solche sachen dann auch zulassen müssen.
Ja ich glaube mit dem modell haben sie ja schon gezeigt was sie für akzeptabel halten emie waren kontakt waren etwa.
Mal gucken.
Ob sich das durchsetzen wird.
Boah.
So wir haben's oder.
Corona boot face oder so cola wie auch immer.
Vielen dank fürs zuhören
bei und nächste woche geht's hier wieder weiter ich hatte auch noch eine eine andere sendung zwischendurch versprochen dazu kam es erstmal nicht mal schauen wie es weitergeht auf jeden fall ist derzeit hier kroner corona gronau wir bleiben weiter dran mit corona weekly und es nimmt.
Viel zeit an aber macht immer noch spaß.
Und wenn sich jemand noch wundern sollte falls ich ein bisschen mich ein bisschen müde anhöre ich habe irgendwie zwei tage durch programmiert also insofern.
Also ich habe letzte nacht habe ich ein bisschen geschlafen aber die nacht davor so ja habe ich.
Ja so viel schlaf finde ich auch nicht ich hänge auch die ganze zeit immer noch am nachrichten-kanal und bin ehrlich gesagt noch ein bisschen fasziniert dass mich das thema immer noch so fasziniert aber es spannend so überleben hat auch was.
Er hat was für sich ja okay jetzt aber.
Wir sagen tschüss vielen dank fürs zuhören vielen dank für eure unterstützung.